tina on est des cadres est enfin là ça
qu'on serait très mal moi je trouve
ouais c'est difficile et on va pouvoir
envoyer le vote fab ouais je suis
heureux qu aujourd'hui cours sur la
première place course dernière place
courses la seconde place qu'est ce que
on va voir on va envoyer le vote fab je
peux pas te dire ce qu'on veut voir je
ne pas
jouer voilà on met quoi on met ou dépôt
ou un
ou une épaule fil rouge à la caf six
rounds à une épaule radjabov
je prie monsieur comme tu veux femmes
c'est moi qui choisis non mais ça que je
dis le vote un élément très fort son
envoi toqué et bah si rundschau ou dépôt
alors attends je mets 5 minutes de vote
1 pour être bien sûr à trois minutes ça
suffit largement aux que non fab
[Rires]
ratez pas bien
nakamura farruggia
ou mais mauro poggia radja donc qu'est
ce que vous voulez voir la course pour
la première place pour la dernière place
le vote qui par toi tu veux toi tu es
plutôt pour les peaux radjabov ce que tu
veux plutôt voir la course pour la
première place mais on verra à résidence
on verra deux ans vers le mode fab ciné
pause s'impose se passer n'importe quoi
ailleurs il va tuer le temps dans donc
ça dépend beaucoup plus de lui que ce
que les autres font ailleurs c'est comme
si enfin c'est une démocratie si c'est à
dire c'est comme si tu as une course
je pars quand un micro devant détachées
bon bah soit ils arrivent à gagner tu as
on sera le chanteur karl scène soit il
aimait fringale et bon bah on verra bien
ce qui se passe après du coup oui mais
mais ici c'est une démocratie fab et
voir
le sprint intermédiaire de tri les oies
pouvoir qui a marqué un beau maillot
vert je pense que les gens veulent
plutôt à brême et je pense les gens elle
plutôt warfare ou de la fab c'est pas
voilà il ya un vote qui en place je t'ai
laissé un vont influencer ce vote non
j'ai pas tellement français mais c'est
donner mon avis tu vois la bêta dès ton
ami et on a quand même voilà laisser
influencer ce vote est pour le moment ta
117 120 voix contre 395 je pense qu'à un
moment donné il fallait ce que pense
vraiment le vote si vous mettez n'est
pour hadja vous aurez droit à une photo
de michel
saraboks à l'autonomie châkidor comme ça
et pas au même endroit que la dernière
fois un nouvelles photos attention
ouais donc sa voix le choix qui va qui
va partir fab pour le moment j'ai envie
de dire qu'il va falloir respecter
les urnes
et 5e la semaine c'était une
proportionnelle
à aurait pas de siège on vous sait qu'en
général
voilà tu es là t'es pas bien je te
laisse quand même un peu de nespouls
radjabov comme aperture je fais à plat
sur le plaisir ces cinq minutes ouais
c'était pas le bon et chicken ouais
c'est un curateur ou 3 mai mais tu avais
tu avais des deux
voilà voilà une catalane je laisse bien
non pas sur moi pas plus d'infos
qui joue le gard en plus ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est la variante 2 qu'il
avait joué en radjabov au norwich s
contre
contre carl scène et c'est la variante
qu'on appelle avoir anticipé end car
dans le milieu les fils un pion la prime
platier c'est ce que je joue avec les
noirs ça m'intéresserait m'ont aussi
particulièrement de suivre cette partie
mais fab c'est la démocratie avant tout
c'est sait pour le moment on a un bon
système devrait pas plutôt
dictature éclairée je ne crois pas à
fable à ses rangs la dictature éclairée
qui perd c'est la démocratie qui va
l'emporter
dommage pour toi qui est dommage pour
vous aussi
dommage pour tout le monde mais on va
profiter ces dernières secondes sur
cette partie fab j'ai envie de se mettre
qu'on se mette les caméras au grand
qu'on se fasse vraiment kiffé voit les
affaires de la nation ses doigts est ce
qu'on pourra voir ça et il ya quelqu'un
qui prend des photos à quatre pattes
là-bas à il part hop hop et sa part
aussi sa part est ca par marché aux
plats aux noms sans rajout il ya même un
contre-pied il fit croire qu'il connaît
pas et fait partir contre-pied tu
reviens à gauche très très bien joué de
la part d' radjabov ouais surtout qu'il
a pris un pion passage en plus sain il
fait d'une pierre deux coups ouais me
fait un peu chaud la côte et radjabov
il fait un petit peu chaud
ce qui va faire tomber la chemise
tommy hunter laisserait aucun moment
donné tu vois il virevolte avec sa
chemise un joueur chemise bleue jeunes
passaient
d'ailleurs radja chemise noire à très
important il faudrait scott du tournoi
je suis passionné j'aime bien la veste
bleue de données peu j'aime bien ce bleu
en fait j'aime toucher des pots la
chemise la vaysse le bide
je suis fan de zéro mais très pentue
pour les peaux gère son c'est son style
de cheveux de coupe il est beau quoi
surtout qu'il enlevait le chignon quoi
mais il fait des grimaces et tout il
joue vite quoi ouais marche free joue
vite il en a rien a dit à chaud la très
très chaud à l issue est issu le chef du
regard gardien hissbach hommes et
regarde ces deux magnifiques fauteuil
femmes oh c'est extraordinaire c'est de
l'ouest à oui là le petit
la petite serviette mais vos poches
poche gauche c'est shirwan avs shirwan à
conrad et chercheur poney hachey konture
boeuf
extraordinaire en plus elles sont bien
mis il a bien miss comme il faut c'est
magnifique ce sera peut-être l'image du
tournoi fab ouais ouais c'est beau un
[ __ ]
france et les vos échecs comme on les
aime voilà elle n'a pas donné de choisit
donc on va quitter ces belles images
ouais pour la voir des joueurs assis qui
font vraiment n'importe quoi
regarde fabiano quand même la classe
comme toujours jolie chemise bleue beau
gosse et comme il est plein de sponsor
il est très bon match championne du
monde il a déjà les sponsors collées
partout à l'ail un genre assez attention
à un tout petit coup de caméra 2 à
des belles images m'ont femmes on
revient avec la moto allez on y retourne
laurent jalabert beau toi comment ça se
passe devant cette partie là bas ses
joueurs n'ont pas mis de veste sur leur
chaise non il fait un peu froid ici pour
le moment fait plus chaud ce sommet de
l'alpe d'huez et ils sont couverts sont
à la descente donc forcément ça coupe
nous du vent ouais le groupe des battus
en train de passer dans le gruppetto
infirmes ou dja est
d'accord il n'a qu'à dans le gruppetto
naka qui a décidé de jouer quatre et qui
a accepté de rentrer dans la nage darf
je crois quand même virulent de la part
d' d'alireza et le cavalier f3 plus
tranquille plus tranquille mais virulent
quand même nom mais jeter l'effroi ça va
annoncer un petit rock
ça va annoncer un petit rock bon je
crois que tu fais comme ces sept là les
normes seraient sinon les blancs vont
faire pousser 4
mais c'est plus du jeu positionnable
cette variante que calais b 3 comme
dépôt avait joué quelques rondes
rencontres contre fillon alors bon choix
mauvais choix côté un haka murat une
info le spécialiste j'ai envie de dire
ce n'est plus à l'homme fabien les
visages ski que je parle mais bien au
grand maître international ex
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
fabien libye zewski acteur de cinéma
fabien libye zf ski grands maîtres à
peine 22 ans des études en sociologie il
a eu le bac avec mention eux
fabien libye zewski eux
peut-être bientôt
oscar dans un nouveau film on ne sait
pas lequel c'est vraiment plus c'est pas
celui qu'on l'appelle aussi fabiano die
liebe zeps kg au
genou le lou sait mais c'est aux grands
maîtres que je parle ici une petite info
qu est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce choix d'ouverture de 10 karuna
camurat hikaru nakamura le joueur
d'échecs hikaru nakamura grand maître
hikaru nakamura streamer ikauno
hommes publicité
sans doute voilà les carreaux nakamura
me sandwich hikaru nakamura
caritatif
pendra qua
non mais son choix écoute il est pas mal
parce que tranquille donc il va imposer
un style de jeu un peu positionnelle
tous ah bon
hikaru seront très déçu de sa prestation
hier au title ah oui on l'a suivi il n'a
pas gagné il a fait que second enfin
troisième d'ailleurs de partage avec
l'ouest les sodi le chat
est en fait de base mais comme le haut
se prononce aussi à aller au match aux
achats exactement exactement ainsi le
chien mais premier du taillage de cf le
fish di feno ce à la et est donc
dans le kouilou un petit je tue plus
tranquille kf3 donc l'idée des blancs
bas comme toujours dans ces structures
c'est de bien vissé cette casse des 5es
de faire pousser 4 petit rock est ce
qu'on peut dire
que le title pour fait das c'est son
sacerdoce
ans arrive donc même si ça ne veut rien
dire je suis sacerdoce effet noces qui
me sont désolés afab un moment vous
tombiez raison
est ce que c'est vrai mais du coup à
lille car boudin caméra qui hier a
réalisé une prestation xxl quand même au
title en battant maxime vachier lagrave
dans une partie où alors que j'étais au
couteau couteau dans une défense assez
assez exceptionnel hors cash et catalans
nous dit le pion dé 6,9 sur java devenir
la cible des attaques des blancs exact
rien qu'est ce que tu penses de ce pion
des six mois je pense qu'il est arriérée
veut l'appeler comme tel alors y avait
c'est un pion une colonne semi-ouverte
qui
s'appliqueront pour le défendre et dont
la caisse devant lui est faible
d'où le web et il est vraiment pas en
forme s'ils ont des 6 en début de partie
à lire et zara qui nous parle un petit
peu de ces pièces musée le pion c5 j'ai
envie de les changer quand même
rapidement un petit peu fatigué et là
c'est vrai que le pion des six aussi à
part toi rumst y tiennent les assauts
adverses sur ses appuis un infâme un
changement à la 65e minute peut-être ont
l'option de tête tu renvoies sa part
annoncé que tu proposes bien ouais que
pâques est la
voie aux alentours de la 60e 65e minute
de jeu on pourrait voir ce pion
s'échanger ou peut-être avancer car
avant cela ce serait la libération
complète
binbin frais qui se remet tout de suite
les muscles on est à quoi s'il vend des
cinq là ça lui permettrait de voir la de
souffler mais tu vois juste histoire de
définition de piora
arriérés formula il est parié alors
qu'il semble tout aussi faible et à rire
est quand même dans la m et moi venant
des cinq peut-être on sait pas c'est pas
vrai là oui là c'est 100%
parce que si une histoire de cases bien
défendu et là beaucoup moins moi je
l'appelle arriérés comme un rappeur un
schéma et si
on sait pas vraiment voilà fort à la
définition officielle r je crois qu un
avant-poste cécile pions la piazze 5 ça
n'avance pas si le puits en eaux cette
ouais ça c'est un avant poste dans des
lacs aux fortes elles changent et la
halle à ses gars sortent
alors qu'en vrai
alors oui bon
c'est la case dessin je regarde les cinq
messages que j'ai vu un excellent
commentaire il faut vraiment qu'on
travaille là-dessus fab c'était sur
youtube et c'est quelqu'un qui nous
suggérer un pour progresser dans aucun
de nos commentaires d' arrêter d'appeler
les cases avec les coordonnées à ce que
non mais c'est vrai que ça gêne à la
lecture du jeu et de plutôt dira le fou
avance de 2 15 ans diagonalistes mes
collages de voilà de gauche il se place
decazes devant le roi pourquoi tu
appelles le pion des finalement le pion
colonne dame comme ça c'était comme cet
avant et oui et c'était mieux mais
peut-être qu'on a régressé dans dans
l'appellation est oui et oui en mettant
ses coordonnées qui geignent finalement
à la compréhension du plateau de jeu là
ok on va reprendre en croit la partie
allait sa part de reprendre la partie
un peu mieux les bleus entament du pion
roi de deux cases les noirs entre
répondent par le pion fou dame de deux
cases sur quoi les plantes développent
le cavalier est le roi sur la colonne du
fou 3 mai une case de vente qui ont
peut-être
hockey
les blancs qui va et enoh qui avancent
leurs pions dame d'une caste et blanc
ans option dame de deux cases les noirs
échange on peut le lire je sais pas on
n'est pas de coordonnées ça va amener
influences qui mange parce que comment
tu sais qui va se faire manger je sais
pas où ils vont être mangés innovants il
mange avec leur leurs pions lampions fou
dont on fout dame le pion fouda colonnes
dame lecavalier reprend le pion qui
venait de prendre ça je pense qu'on peut
le dire ce que tu comprends dans le et
le cavalier côté droit se développe sur
la case côté centrale peut dire sa
colonne fou devant deux pions denis
droite à qui attaquent le pion central e
lecavalier brillante vient se déplacer
pour centrale us a chuté à l'option
centrale les mauvaises habitudes qui
reviennent je suis éliminé femmes c'est
soit qu'il fallait avoir terminé en roue
libre l'épreuve des poteaux les blancs
développent leurs cavaliers dame sur la
colonne du fou devant le pion et
défendre ainsi l'option centrale qui
était attaqué
les barres latérales complètement à
droite deux couples autour d'une case
on ne sait pas trop alors qu'ils
défendent la case en diagonale devant
lui sur la colonne du cavalier voilà sur
la couleur blanche
jean pierre oger peut-être que la claire
classe peut-être classe que
d'avoir les plantes développent le fou
dame voilà devant le roi devant droit le
plus proche possible des endroits sur
quoi les noirs pousse le pion à deux
cases pour attaquer le cavalier centrale
qui se replient là où il était
précédemment
et les noirs développe l'autre cavalier
sur une posture centrales à gaz naturel
taille voilà c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus compréhensible servat
s'est d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous dit
m2i cannes quoi avant le comprenez rien
aux échecs maintenant j'y vois clair
merci banon mais de rien sur mon
progresse on essaye on lit vos
commentaires on essaye voilà de
progresser petit à petit et le joueur
américain à la chemise bleue
étaient en train de réfléchir et ce qu'
il doit développer sa dame et l'avancée
d'une case en avant pour après libérer
son roi qui pourrait partir côté dames
pour jean coup spécial à un coût qui
ferait bouger le roi et la tour en une
seule fois ça c'est pas tout le monde
qui peut le faire ou est-ce qu'il va
développer le le fou côté roy de cases
clair ouais je ferai ça devant le cavaly
ça a l'air d'être logique
visé
dans la diagonale rebond on va dire on
va plus ça comme ça
vers le pion que tu es roi noir à côté
du roi avec elle juxtapose quelque part
adjacent
attaqué le pur adjacent
mais je vais faire ce coup là je vais
partir ou jeune je regardais dans la
base de données c'est assez rare mais
ces dépôts qu'il a joué deux fois dans
sa dans sa carrière paul hogan deux fois
c'est très rare en fait comme
en général c'était plus le développement
du froid d'une case
de la dame d'une petite pièce en déveine
adjacentes
voilà c'était plutôt les coups normaux
jusqu'à lors
il se valide âmes qui se développe
beaucoup plus rare seulement seulement
80 parties dans la base alors que des
toc tente ben oui faut faire des
multiplications la augmente entre bosses
ouais ou autant toile et deux marches je
pense
et je sais pas je crois que non poteau
de vaud dans le contrôle dans le canton
de vaud je crois qu'ils disent
hoquetante hoquetante et sinon c'est
aussi très
83e 85e est-ce que ça ne nuit pas à la
compréhension aussi ça que ces trésors
80 comment merci ouais tu vas faire des
multiplications c'est déjà assez
compliqué comme ça à fabien ont 18 ans
par 80 mais je crois que ton canton de
vaud
ils disent obtenteurs dans les villages
pas j'ai un peu vécu en suisse si on va
dire en fait les vrais vaudois vous
déformez dépôt
80 ans à 10 cm ces mets ici vallon des
villages du canton des du canton de vaud
ils disent plutôt hoquetante
tuân avis aux cantons en suisse je crois
que si et je crois que si
non mais à lausanne ces foules 8 en mai
mais on m'a dit justement voilà lausanne
ces foules 80 mais si tu vas
voir
on l'aurait terroir quoi
j'ai vécu à genève donc c'est pas loin
du canton de vaud
est apparemment ouais c'est à lausanne
convient plus tôt alors que voilà
on peut on peut aller dans le vrai
terroir du canton de vaud et est entendu
hoquetante qui part
donc qui sait si jouer ça surprend un ac
a way
n'était pas prêt pensif 1 le joueur
américain
on n'y a pas besoin title celui-là hier
à moncton high tone jeu vocal f 3,3 b3
les deux sont dits en suisse
effectivement en belgique en revanche
c'est 70 80 et 90 ils ont vraiment
aucune loi perben 2 belge c'est
70 80 90 yens
980 pourquoi terrible
octobre c'est joli
on peut faire un pari sur les prochains
kunda ou peut être
l'influencé en plus
achetons ce assez ce dès qu'ils veulent
me pousser 4
c'est logique quand même
des quatre photos signées cent face à la
logique au 6
mai
croix dessus
des 5
ce que en général quand il ya cette
structure et blanc n'ont pas super envie
d'échanger certes sa double les pions
mais ça renforce le contrôle central de
cette caisse des cinq très très
importante ce pion n'est pas faible sur
l' attaque très facile à défendre et les
noirs vont faire flouer 7 ils vont re ok
ils ont cette colonne f pour la tour
aussi la dame pourrait peut-être sera
menée par là bas le cavalier ou un
trajet pour se placer ici est
potentiellement une poussée un jour donc
ça c'est plutôt une bonne structure côté
noir c'est pour ça quand tu y as
possibilités des changes les blancs bas
soit le recul le fou comme ça c'est une
reprennent bas ils ont tout perdu
puisque ils échangent le fou qui était
censée contrôler ça donc les blancs
reprennent et ces terrains soit
soit sept autres options souhaite le
cavalier parce qu'on menace au passage
to b 6 s'est qualifiée cette donc on n'a
pas le temps de prendre tout la belle
prépare un dossier aux services
et de surprendre
est ce que tu penses que firent ou
rêvent encore de la victoire dans ces
candidats de tout le monde en rêve mais
après objectivement espérons 6/10 joule
bien aujourd'hui ban à carreaux noir the
banner peau noire et je suis là
ce que s'il gagne ses deux parties au
noir il est de retour quand même investi
là combien il à 200 ou t'es pas trop
trop mal quand je n'en
ferais qui gagne les cinq prochaines
parties pour là une chance donc
tu peux toujours te dire que c'est bon
quoi enfin je sais pas mais
il reste encore caruana au noir aussi
calme aidera les blancs bombés
du seigle raconte carole contre une voie
facile quoi by carreaux noirs tubes
années peau noire tuba caruana noire
était en cours ce
faisable oui de la tête star mais
c'est vrai que là encore la course pour
la deuxième place mais après je me pose
une question philosophique
si on faisait même répondent en tchat
est ce que si karl scène ne joue pas le
match du championnat du monde on pourra
dire que tout ce cycle a été fait juste
pour rien et que les tournois qu'on
regarde depuis
un an servent réellement à rien dans le
sens où si tout ça pour ça j'ai envie de
dire
sinon j'ai une bonne nouvelle après mais
c'est ma question que se posent à toi et
au chat mais
bon moi mon avis hein c'est que si
jamais c'est comme ça je veux pas de
match en fait je que je fais un quart
des candidats sur champion du monde
c'est pour ça que je pose la question à
chaque match ou alors je refais des
candidats et de vainqueur des 2e
candidats affrontent
ce que pour moi ce serait un peu faussé
que le deuxième participerait pas
pourquoi non mais j'aime pas du tout en
fait
de la merde
non mais regardez candidat devient
champion du monde et puis c'est tout le
problème
par contre j'ai une bonne nouvelle ok
les candidats femme oui pour être joué
en match 1 c'était en grande discussion
mais là ça y est c'est acté la fidh a
peut-être enfin compris que les tournois
étaient
champ pour plein de raisons et pas
vraiment équitable finale comme on le
voit et ils ont décidé pour les
candidates du coup de faire ça en match
alors c'est des matches en quatre
parties pour les quarts d'heure les demi
finales et un match en six parties qui
sera joué après la finale je ne sais
quel est le style est championne du
monde jouait john
labatt chine à l'autre en finale elle a
battu kari chouinard est pas ce que vous
en faites les derniers candidate
jacqueline avait trop écrasée de tournoi
tout est joueuse et elle a rampé est-ce
qu'on joue quoi fin qu'est ce qu'on fait
là au moins balata perdu en quarts de
finale bah tu peux rentrer chez toi quoi
tu écoutais mieux tu souffles mais même
pour ce tournoi ce serait beaucoup plus
sympa fin l'année peau aurait pas de
point de pluie sera en finale contre
quelqu'un d'autre on aurait des u10
partie on sera la deuxième partie du non
en fait et je crois qu'ils veulent jouer
les quarts de finale les demi finales
finale un peu plus décalé longtemps
ouais je crois c'est bien tu ailles
peloton est grand plus on est sympa
tout ça dans le foot est roi où fo b3
très bien il ya beaucoup principaux va
tu fais foulée 3 ou caïds et 5 je sais
pas quelle merde et foulée trois mâts
leur
courrier avant on va dire à quelle
position
moi j'ai mis ça dans le bonne nouvelle
quand même que c'est une bonne nouvelle
chez pas toi c'est comment tu les
accueille cette nouvelle comme une
nouvelle mais ne s'est pas mal voici
fait vingt dix ans les deux formes entre
les deux formats me vont mais alors on
avait plus sûr c'est sympa des matches
rien tournoi c'est long et ça peu
ce qui est bien sûr que là ce tournoi en
fait on regarde parce que bon on attend
la fin mais moi j'aime pas trop le fait
qu'en fait ça cela maintenant et pau il
va jouer que contre des faire valoir
entre guillemets c'est une course entre
nemo et caruana ils ont déjà joué entre
eux donc en quelque sorte a l'impression
que c'est c'est des plots qui décide
ouais qui va gagner ou ne pas gagner le
tournoi sur nains qui suicide on se bat
afin vendant les aidants là dans la
matière qui se laisse perdre dans la
partie waouh fin
alors que dans match en fait tu
m'uses à vérifier tu veux éliminer le
mec way et je trouve ça assez sympa moi
je fais enfin j'aimerais bien qu'ils
adaptent aussi ce format pour le par
contre pas ce que je veux dire c'est que
niveau spectacle possible qui est
beaucoup plus de nul de gestion dans les
matches à pression oui bien qu'elle
était pas mais wydra départage mettra
peut-être quatre jours de conflit ont
fait nul ou la whey jetez pas sur une
ouverture de meyrin ge nuls 4 x 100 var
et ce devoir est bon le partage
évidemment là tu te sur la gueule c'est
bien et donc peut-être on a une bonne
journée et ou deux bonnes journées sur
cinq alors que là au moins il se bat
tous comme des phares oui mais à partir
des demi finales je pense qu'on quarts
de finale quant à quatre parties sur les
4 on a forcément une qui joues et tu va
forcément avoir un gars qui va gagner
donc sur le premier tour le quart de
finale tu va forcément avoir une partie
où tu es un mec qui va être mené au
score au moins ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
aient 8 nuls direct sans jouer
et quand bien même
parce que on voit dans les matchs
étaient moins enclins à prendre des
risques là tu sais que tu peux revenir à
tapant une perle mais ça joue plus mais
bon au pire tu as des beautés partage
faites moi je peux faire une belle
journée des partages en rapide ou s'en
voit de partout et 4 mauvaise journée de
l'ong façon les longues ça n'intéresse
quasiment personne vocal guma faut mieux
du regard oui bon bah là quarts de
finale des candidats aujourd'hui à 4
rapide c'est le feu tu vois tu plonges
windows le matin de l'apref tu peux
vraiment de faire kiffer mais par contre
pour une programmation un peu comme ça
vous chaque match est un peu vrai un peu
décalée des deux le matin de l'âme c'est
pas tous en même temps six à quatre
matchs si on a deux ans le matin à
l'après midi tu peux vraiment faire un
très beau moi je trouve c'est la bonne
nouvelle
non mais ce sera contrastée des matches
je suis pas mécontent qui la finale ok
mais la finale en six parties c'est
intéressant c'est comme une demi finale
de championnat du monde tu vois ouais
c'est [ __ ] tu vas six parties machin
c'est décalé dans le temps d'agir c'est
comme s'ils allaient candidats bon là ça
s'arrête et puis bon on reprend dans un
mois pour la grande finale par waza
vidéo enfin ok c'est cool et puis ça
fait sens par rapport au fait que
derrière c'est encore un match
championnats du monde or franchement
plus le même format quoi on dit souvent
que ce sont des trucs qui sont pas bons
pour pour
pour le côté intéressant du public là
autant ils font ça ils réduisent les
cadences [ __ ] tu as enfin un événement
que tu as envie de regarder non mais tu
imagines le délire c'était en fait tu
dis ça je vais m'asseoir j'ai envie de
regarder
mais c'est hyper rare d'un toit d'échec
que tu as juste envie de regarder voir
est
ce moi ci fondée mais moi je te signale
que les départage quarts de finale des
candidats je peux passer ma journée sur
mes gens réellement parce que là si je
commande pas évidemment je vais pas
regarder comme tout le monde en fait
mais si c'est des rapides je te jure je
peux être assis le matin l'après-midi
enfin battu les oraux que oui hoballah
je peux être heureux c'est très sympa
en tout cas ça je trouve que c'est une
très bonne idée en plus c'est cohérent
c'est une cohérence avec le
sait pas les échecs c'est des matchs
quoi céder confrontation de style tu
vois ouais non mais après moi comme d'un
virage à jamais un truc parfait je
rentre chatenay ils peuvent donner comme
comme contre argument est que tu peux
avoir un tableau facile pas mais bon
c'est la vie ça reste dans le tennis
adam tan tan et football dans le tennis
absolument tous les sports du monde ça
c'est des matchs en fait c'est tout le
temps des malins mais est ce que tu es
bien sûr
un vrai bon c'est pas bien sûr ouais
mais tu as envie de voir si les échecs
c'est un combat c'est une confrontation
entre deux hommes quoi c'est c'est
l'essence même du jeu en fait j'aimerais
me autour de 1,28 ronde quoi quand même
ouais moi après voilà si tu prend par
les sentiments tournant 28 rendent là je
te dis oui candide en voiture ont
d'ailleurs là y aurait personne qui
serait éliminé ah bah non il reste
encore 18 rond madou d'autres termes je
n'ai que trois points de retard à les
combes linge s'échauffer joie quand ils
jouent maintenant je déploie ma vraie
puissance toi tu croyais mais regarde
plus timides et poids sur les épaules
non c'est sûr
non mais bon soit quand je partage des
bonnes nouvelles c'est fin c'est
vraiment une bonne nouvelle enfin
monsieur coup reçu à des matches c'est
cool sur fond un tournoi ça son intérêt
mais oui non mais les matchs très bien
s'ils font des matches et malema s'est
quand même au dessus ça me va bien
maintenant c'est bon
moi je suis un coup j'étais petit
c'était les matchs des candidats
élus car peuvent tous peuvent rêver
d'une carte off and land
karpov short il est perdu
les candidats chantent team-aaa mais
l'histoire des échecs en plus sévères et
puis
et puis même à près de 6 des pc hors
match et elle cycle de
la fidh c'étaient des matches
c'est émanant de gamme ce qui je crois
way
you qu'un pape calme ce qui aussi amsata
fall et liste à 96
des
eaux était plein de matchs sympas même
le crown chirac pour le booster un match
le perdant se qualifier mais c'est les
matches qui sont quand même restés plus
dans l'histoire qu'autre chose regarde
le championnat du monde de san luis et
le seul on s'en fout en fait pas
beaucoup le temps est menacé par a
d'ailleurs pour moi c'est un sport
spyker essais par match non mais c'est
cool qu'ils aient fait des matches comme
quoi les gens se plaignent 10 à grands
pas les matches machin aux pieds dans
les airs et
gelé les bénéficies 02 fischer c'était
des matches
j'arrive
donc c'était des matches exceptionnels
ce qu'ils font le mieux mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'après paraître
tournoi qui marque focus toi sois cool
donc le jury que 53 on l'a tous en tête
c'est à cause du l'ifab a peut-être
c'est pas corps et une offre haut débit
au début 30 ouais mais c'était pas un
candidat en fait lui c'est juste un
boulot mais c'est un savon est énorme et
géré par le long de 2013 ensuite il
était bien
voilà
pensons pas faillite et vend bien mais
pas ces circonstances là on y vient
aussi en fait le disons les matches
c'est sûr tu un vrai enjeu
important le tournoi des dépendants de
ce qui se passe tu peux pas être sûr à
l'avant ce que ce sera cool le temps et
de san luis 2005 est formidable sauf que
c'est le truc qui manque qui a laissé le
moindre surtout bon c'est en vrai
entachée de rumeurs et de ses traits
particuliers san luis
l'orchidée 5 joué par michael pont qu'on
parlait donc ils refusent les champs
enfin il faut des changes il place sa
pièce sur la cas soir mais n'a pas
échangé et donc ils menacent le fameux
foulée 6 et
alors joindre est parti deux manières de
répondre pour les noirs le peut-être de
plus logique c'est tour s'est vite qui
sommes pas trop mal
l'autre manière de faire c'est tout est
changé là dessus c'est une partie de mes
pots qui a une rencontre karim je pense
c'est du rapide c'est du rapide il a
fait un truc n'est pas aux jeux parce
que ça où il a fait fou prend
du coup grand mettons cavalli prend dame
prendre ces logiques
garder une pièce sur cette case plutôt
qu'un pion même si des fois on peut
discuter de la structure comme ça non à
une majorité alda mais bon dans l'idéal
on préfère faire ça et là il fait ça
pour pour une petite finale il l'avait
tenue ouais mais oui bon mais jean reno
saphir ou va pas jouer sans meneur et de
rambo voilà et puis surtout il va la
perdre
d'autres manières de faire évidemment
donc c'est de faire publicité en soit
c'est un problème pour mc qui a été sept
après fourchette tout fait pour c'est
vite dit qu'il
irait coup d'ailleurs principal dans la
position sur quoi il ya bouffe f6
tous prison de 6
il est deux fois d'empreintes faut être
franc
je prendrais de f
peut-être que ça
même de la dame avoue être le truc c'est
que les blancs ils ont échangé de fleurs
ils ont échangé des pièces qu'ils
défendent et sariska lui très loin dont
il va falloir trouver comment le
manoeuvrer un truc comme ça à terme
et les partis jouent là-dessus l'une des
maximes je veux ça avec les blancs en
2009 contre morrow à bienne
aurait pris de la dame
ok il savait était assez égal à aimer ça
rock fawcett qui a aidé 2 pour amener
peut-être faire ce plan-là dont je parle
a éludé 5 logique un
ouf dame g4 petit rock
devenu après après je sais pas un petit
a dit sur trois jeux 6 ou quoi
il était gamin davantage c'est vrai il
est fait ça ça
ça on est mieux c'en est mieux donc
peut-être des cinq impératifs mais bon
ok je suis pas très inquiet avec ce que
j dans le tchad juste fabuleux second on
nous dit que les matches c'est un format
beaucoup plus aléatoire je crois pas
dans l'histoire des échecs les matchs et
souvent couronnées des joueurs moins
forts sûrement pas au match de
championnat du monde absents que c'est
quand même très souvent le le plus forte
qui l'a emporté et ça a été prouvé
souvent dans les tournois après les
championnats du monde je pense même à
cramique quand il bat kasparov qui a
petit à petit bon on va dire que c'est
je prends les matches les plus
surprenants entre guillemets parce que
si on commence à apprendre car olsen
kasparov qui gagne tous ses matches et
tout ça l'est moins mais où kramnik
l'écho ce genre de choses après le
joueur qui gagne il domine quand même
généralement le monde des échecs bon le
truc qui est grave c'est un peu un
tremblement de terre était calme hier
jour au monde oui mais c'est géré c'est
le match le plus surprenant de toute
l'histoire de da soit ça soit crown of
pop alexis 9 oui mais l'éclaté bourg et
oui mais vers la f1 hockey et situe fin
si tu bois une demi bouteille de vodka
tous les soirs ça change quand même
certains trucs mais mais sinon rire
général le champion du monde sait pas
c'est un charlot
nom et son fils et son challenger non
plus
je connais pas did you cry en finale non
non il dit ben l'exemple du raisin
restant sur deux matchs investisseurs
deux parties en fait cesser ces
terribles en fait de toujours rester
difficile par les clubs schatz qui
prennent toujours des egos comme petite
france ah ouais mais au des chaussures
en championnat comme le football mais le
football ce n'est pas un sport un v1
individuel
absolument rien à voir on peut pas
comparer des sports collectifs les
sports individuels sont souvent comme ça
et dans les matchs aux échecs quand tu
mets six parties là par exemple ok tu
vas avoir peu de surprise quand même un
ont six parties
ah oui tu peux perdre une mais
normalement encore 5 pour faire la
différence c'était plus forte et plus
fort
ouais ouais après voilà tu peux être
m'enfin je le trouvais que c'est que de
toute façon faut bien qu'à une petite
incertitude du sport
même la 1 et pau personne n'aurait mis
plus fort avant le début des candidats
s'il gagne il était 9e mondiale celle
enfin je pense que tu le ton à 10 fois
c'est pas les pots qui le gagne 10 fois
surtout non marche à la confiance
mais je veux dire c'est la même chose
dans pas comment vous dire moi
[Musique]
c'est comme s'ils voulaient arrêter les
coupes du monde au foot c'est peut-être
pas la meilleure équipe qui gagne à
chaque fois et c'est peut-être le cas je
sais pas ce qu'en 98 la france était la
meilleure équipe du monde non ces débats
table enfin peut-être en 2000 oui mais
en train 18h09 alors bon attaquant
bon ben spies qu'italie était plus forte
quand même en
2001-2002 france est vraiment forte
en
2002 c'était sur cette forme mais bon
déjà mais non en 2000 c'était en fait en
gros c'était 80 minutes plus tard henry
devant quoi et puisque la confiance
accumulée donc
en 2018 tu pensais à la meilleure équipe
moi je pense que je vais pas sûr mais on
n'était pas mal en 2018 je pense pas que
la belgique quand même vu leur
domination du matinal était plus forte
non mais pour le coup en fait j'aurai
deux coupes du monde à deux mois
d'intervalles n'aurait pas le même
vainqueur
est ce que tu penses mathieu que si on
rejoue la saison de ligue 1 une deuxième
fois bordeaux est quand même relégué
mais peut-être même santé mais je pense
que oui avec
s'en sortir à bordeaux mais je pense
qu'il est trop tôt et même dans leur
club je suis pas niveau ambiance niveau
il ya un problème quoi
problèmes financiers que je suis pas des
rumeurs de faillite de trucs peut-être
et synthes il yad'autres présidente je
pense pour se battre avec elle annonce
solennellement que si on gagne à
l'euromillions vendredi on rachète
sainté on en a parlé tout à l'heure en
fait on joue à leurs vignes ont toujours
acheter ses intérêts
l'organe pas le robin buck mais bon on
prendrait sainte et les deux présidents
finito
[Rires]
et des tons les revendre en direct en
fait en fait une fois qu'on a acheté on
a rempli on revend à d'abord voir
quelqu'un d'autre
sur personne complètement battu
c'est la seule je crois qu'on a eu 44
millions si on gagne 176 on peut le
faire quoi
on crée une structure c'est un football
manager grandeur nature
donc ça c'est pas lappartient femmes non
non c'est qu'il y ait des cinq jouer un
métier
certain sur ses suites ouais
ok je suis un peu étonné je sais pas
encore réfléchi option
je suis un califat et du champion du
monde ce n'était vraiment pas le
meilleur aujourd'hui non mais il n'est
pas champion enfin c'est terrible en
fait toujours enfin non mais en fait ici
ses coûts connaissent et connaissent et
de quoi vous parlez on ne parlait en
fait c'étaient pas des matches champion
du monde c'était le format coupe du
monde et puis on
n'était pas là et bajard histoire jouée
par exemple je pense qu'à nantes jouait
pas
c'est pas du tout respecté ce truc mais
d'ailleurs quand tu réalises des
champions du monde classique c'est
important il n'y a pas qu'à une femme de
n'en ai pas pu dormir dedans y'a pas
topalov dehors
ils n'ont pas gagné le truc normal par
contre un qui aurait pu faire une grande
carrière et qui a gagné ce championnat
c'est ponomariov met les nerfs ont lâché
très vite oui alors que c'est un joueur
assez extraordinaire ponot était en
forme
et ou alors il a soufflé quoi je sais
pas mais là maintenant quand il joue il
s'en fout vraiment un
bonheur absolu le pauvre le pauvre il
aime vraiment faim omeyer et puis j'ai
déménagé lui en espagne
et puis travail a maintenu un très bon
niveau et des perles à 2007 mais tient à
quelqu'un par contre qu'il quelque chose
d'intéressant dépôt il a la chance entre
guillemets un bien sûr de jouer nding
grondin avec les noirs qui étaient dans
des dispositions
horrible et qu'il ait suivi donne la
game et oui c'est pas parce que tu fais
en 14 secondes que t'as pas le côté
réussit un c'est ça c'est vraiment du
fin c'est du vol et nommée l'ordre d
attention parce que faite aux débutants
à tourner à fond après s'il souffre de
même qu'à la tête dans fond du trou et
que tu leur joug en neuf c'est mieux que
leur jeu rondeurs enfin
oui mais c'est enfin la digne de rondins
c'était vraiment idéal
c'est fou que ding il arrive pas
s'arranger avec avec la chine pour
gay vivant si ça c'est pas le problème
mais s'il a un tournoi qui le laisse
tranquille quoi ça va partir une semaine
avant je reviendrai vous inquiétez pas
je vais bien dormir je met en condition
sérail ou l'avant veille évidemment il
est décalqué quoi enfin
normal et puis puis ils n'ont pas filé
le visa compter les tournois qu'il
aurait pu jouer ça peut être en norvège
ou décrocher ce tour des trucs
et c'est dur pour ding en fait fins
c'est dommage alors que j'aime bien mes
derniers candidats déjà
il l'avait confié quoi donc là c'est dur
car c'est évidemment tu étais pas dans
son état est hélas oui mais ils arrivent
de chine la veille qu'enfin vous non
mais c'est n'importe qui aurait eu du
mal à jouer enfin c'est très dur taiba
mercredi soir tu joues vendredi après
midi fins et sait pas non plus combien
d'heures de vol il s'est tapé mais
sûrement beaucoup parce qu'ils habitent
même pas dans une grande forme en suisse
les villes sont beaucoup plus grandes en
chine que chez nous mais comparativement
aux grandes villes chinoises évidence
d'une vie je crois relativement
provincial donc j'imagine qu'il a dû
prendre minimum trois vols
de faire son petit truc pour shanghai
shanghai chez paou je sais pas où dubaï
dubai madrid en fait la seule chose de
ding bugs et si les candidats
s'organisent en chine quoi
et que tout le monde a le problème
inverse ton visa il commence jeudi
[Musique]
et puis en plus lui aussi doit avoir un
problème d'acclimatation à la nourriture
etc à l inverse de nous si on veut enfin
jamais si on va en chine on va un peu
suez je pense d'abord après maintenant
je pense qu'il a l'habitude avec un
bonjour beaucoup jours il est bon quand
il doit savoir ce qu'ils peuvent mais
maison pas et peut-être que oui il doit
connaître un peu les endroits parce que
d'après ce que je sais
comme nous on peut attraper la turista
quand on va
à eux aussi en fête
et jean marie pierre souvent ils sont
intolérants au lactose parce que les ont
pas les en imoca
je préfère microbiote intestinal et en
sueur face à face à notre mode
alimentaire alimentaires et même face
aux bactéries qu'on a dans notre ou quoi
bon nous moussaoui mais en fait je ils
sont donc arrivés deux jours avant un
tournoi pareil c'est juste fou en fait
l'appel à qui passe mal quoi l epa irak
sont pas bien nettoyer quoi
bunga-bunga
nom de sweet change vous avez voté
d'ailleurs au bas où il a eu beau
attendre démocratie d'
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
faire un tour des stades peut-être dans
un moment mais là c'est pour ses films
au format seulement for mac on réfléchit
après qu'il ait des singles
mais ouais mais donc du coup elle se
fait de jouer dingoo noir qui fait une
partie vraiment kata et tous et c'est
sûr que tu as un côté réussite est née
peau qui en a profité après faut aussi
être là et prendre le plus tôt 1 c'est
pas gagné d'avancé mais c'est tellement
important plus pour un joueur comme
dépôt pour lui un pour lui paris perd
clairement fait sentir et des sept
partis ça me fait penser
un hand à rognan d'une 14
première ronde des candidats un anti
marshall ou à rognan fait pas l'autre
fait il ya un coup de mou fait qu'à 5
qui a priori été un peu connus tout ça
va mais ba ni l'un ni l'autre avec un
tour à 6 tours g6 qui par là bas et il
n'a pas fait à nong et de la partie
sam est sur les bons rails
[Musique]
ouais mais c'est ça se joue souvent les
détails le les niveaux sont tellement
serrés
on demande s'ils figurent ou alors très
pop et je comprends pas en quoi ils
devraient pas l'être mais il a l'air de
l'être et donc je ne comprends pas trop
effectivement
parce que tango vont revenir à cette
position qu'on a vu des milliers de fois
il ya deux grands coups pour les blancs
c'est là où la cac et mes trois c'est
faire f3 d'amd de grand roque en gros le
grandes lignes et c'est la partie de
dépôt contre rogers et kf3 c'est l'autre
manière de jouer plus positionnelle ont
fait pousser quatre petits rock et on
joue pour cette case c'est plus fond de
court mais c'est un gros gros coup
calais franc je ne sais pas c'est par
rare avec 15 parties dans la basse
mais du coup après calisesi enfin été
joué que les coûts principaux qui
haïssez 6 pouces et quatre c'est qu'ils
saisissent il réfléchit pour jouer mais
tu dis bon mais il doit penser à ce qui
là après moi mais c'est sûr qu'il a
préparé un truc bombana kaïm et le
foulard même moi si je n'ai pas la
position j'aurais fait venir mon ca
batna j'ai deux options c'est ça ou ça
donc avec les normes du travail deux
coups
je suis là bas tu la sors ce que tu fais
quand même non mais c'est ce dont on
discute et au ici avec vlad l'autre soir
à dîner c'est que la préparation de fil
rouge à le truc c'est qu'ils ont fait
quelque chose de très très ambitieux
sous la houlette de chroniques et que et
que c'est complètement raté en fait il a
dû apprendre trop truc il est venu très
épuisés au parti quand on sent que ça va
pas du tout en fait après j'ai
l'impression voir le problème ça mais
[Musique]
mais j'ai l'impression que i live il a
mal ciblé sa prépa ouais elle est très
bien mais elle est trop ambitieuse et
des fois pas bien pensé et des fois pas
ouais des fois pas bien pensée par
rapport à son style de jeu à lui on
pense notamment à la catalane contre
caruana
par exemple en fait où le 4 contre duda
vas-tu switch les deux parties wen jouer
quatre familles qui va devenant des
espagnols compliqué où tu fais ton
italienne enfin ils choisissent qui fait
mais
1.456 jouent ils comptent doodle te
casser les dents sur sa petrov où il n'y
avait même pas 10 des bas d'ailleurs tu
fais une catalane quoi et où tu joues ok
to he sizhu et
on dit mais firova film policier plus
tarder cette prépa c'est vrai aussi ça
fait partie de sa progression et mais
bon fin ça n'empêche pas qu'il va
falloir changer
changer des choses pour pour les
prochains candidats c'est aussi une
expérience c'est pas mauvais
ça doit servir pour la suite way en ôta
de façon peut-être de boulot différence
et on travaille à long terme des rageux
meilleurs joueurs et quand tu fais un
tournoi c'est pour réussir si nous
tournons en question surtout quand c'est
des candidats à ces deux tournois
tu ne joues pas en disant ouais c'est
pas grave je progressais pour la suite
ça m'a dit we came et pour progresser
doit passer par la regarde n'est pas
leurs dépôts à gagner ses premiers
candidats quand même donc là dans la
situation de fil rouge à il avait déjà
gagné est il en passe de gagner c'est
deuxième candidat donc
c'est compliqué après c'est pas une
mauvaise chose et ont exporté passe très
régulièrement par des échecs pour mieux
rebondir mais c'est sûr qu'il faudra
tirer les leçons mais oui de toute façon
il va falloir qu'il se trouve un bon
second dans principal en fait avec une
belle relation de confiance ou pas
d'ailleurs j'en ai investi dans les
meilleurs tapas d'anciens champions du
monde en fait dans les meilleurs seconds
en actuelle kazim oui mais oui c'est
pour ça que j'aime et monte à kazim
tabac qui dans ceux qui sont très
reconnus tamil scène on flatte pas
malade mais v'là dossier où il n'empêche
et en fait c'est des joueurs
ils sont arrivés dans le top mondial
plus ou moins
non mais même des to back to the mac os
bas à même de doré diam's qui s'auto
coteaux reagan qui est mort ya pas
longtemps nikitine dans tous les grands
seconds en hockey a longtemps s'il ya
pas de champion du monde en fait un bon
tout ça il n'y a pas cinquante deux
champions du monde non mais on la verra
dans dix secondes personnes enfin
peut-être que donne un coup de main mais
c'est pas un second temps mais gary non
plus il fait ça là il file à un peu des
cartes sont à un moment un peu hikaru
mais je pense plus des stages que
qu'autres choses
du monde si karpov j'ai jamais entendu
qu'il faut c'est quelqu'un quelque part
on a dit oui car aucun et puis
[Musique]
de toute façon voilà il n'a pas 12
millions
dont peut-être une bonne idée ou pas je
ne sais pas mais faut que le gars en
question en fait soit complètement
investi de sa mission est peut-être un
peu comme au foot en fait tu es
entraîneur tu as beau raté un énorme
joueur tu veux mettre les joueurs en
lumière c'est plutôt à la star
il faut accepter ça ces joueurs qui
brillent quoi
tu dois arriver à les faire briller
dubai où tous les nombres ou d'autant
que j'ai vu passer en fait c'est pas des
seconds en mayenne cd et des personnes
qui sont en vente dans l'équipe ça c'est
différent les comptes par on parle que
de seconde on line après tout ces gens
là qui sont en fait c'est comme aller
dans le foot on reprendre le foot à
l'entraîneur savita les adjoints à
l'entraîneur des gardiens d'alan s-vidéo
te tue pas le staff que tu veux mais tu
as l'entraîneur en chef
qui disent on a la vision globale des
choses les points à travailler
ils tous à quoi
est ce gala doit avoir vraiment d'être
investie à fond vive pour ça et
avoir une belle relation de confiance
avec le joueur quoi
ça demande beaucoup de qualités en fait
c'est un travail très très compliquée
s'ils sont souvent open moi je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas voilà il ya ba qui
embrasse ils veulent mais c'est ce que
l'arc et une équipe autour qui peut
changer d'ailleurs selon le travail
selon un mec qui peut être plus sur la
green fee la nôtre plus sur autre chose
un autre qui doit lui trouver des idées
sur sur les anglais cependant il ya des
règles je sais pas tout juste pour aider
un petit peu à ce rotor qui n'oseraient
pas dans le chatt quelqu'un tu écris la
rapide c'est un autre sport que les
parties longues
si deux marathoniens fondu on leur fait
courir un sprint au départage alors pas
tout à fait je crois pas que parce qu'en
fait le numéro un en rapide des envies
de faim c'est souvent le même que que
dans le que dans les longueurs que je
pense pas que usain bolt soit fort en
marathon et que le champion du monde de
marathon que je ne connais pas
malheureusement
les meilleurs ça tu te rends avec
teignant au 100 m - marché et ceni 4 100
m 200 m en fait c'est quasiment la même
chose des meilleurs en rapides sont les
meilleurs en longues et des meilleurs en
longues sont les meilleurs en blitz très
souvent c'est à peu près toujours
toujours les mêmes joueurs qui sont dans
un bon jour et un premier
break il aura une plus grande spéciale
des pompes pour l'eau de germaine on a
souvent dit qui renaît un peu plus
difficile dans les rapides
oublier quand même top 10 ou le top 15
mondial alors que bon en long il est
mieux il est numéro 2 claire ou 3 mai
dans le top 5 on va dire à coup sûr en
blitz rapide un peu moins kevin nom est
levé le meilleur rapide qu'en longue
alors maxime il est 9 8e ou 9e mondial
en longue je pense pas qu'ils passent
cinq millièmes mondiale en rapide et
150e mondial en blitz en fait il est
dans le top 10 dans les trois cas danse
c'est toujours à peu près les mêmes
joueurs qui sont au top une fois que tu
as fait 12 nuls ou 14 nuls en partie
longue un moment donné faut bien
départager les gens d'une manière et x
ou y
du coup on a vu qu'ils avaient le même
niveau en langues on imagine si après
douze partis comme le match contre
caruana ya eu 12 nuls ben il faut bien
les départager d'une manière x ou y non
mais si vous dites le tennis le tie
break qu'elle est
et jeux normaux c'est pas le même jeu ok
ça c'est pas tout à fait pareil mais
comme ta raquette et puis oui il a fallu
tenir six jeux partout où comme au foot
après c'est après s'être déjà les 2
pénaltys et pas comme les matches mais
au bout d'un moment si les deux équipes
pour un niveau similaire enfin vaut
mieux jouer ça faut jouer à la pièce
jouée à quoi puis bon là pour la peine
aux échecs en rapide ou en longue c'est
quand même à peu près le même top 10 1
c'est à peu près le même top 10 a
quelque chose à faire non mais c'est pas
un jeu différent qu enfin c'est pas on
va jouer au hasard parce que c'est du
rapide
il faut bien les jambes personnellement
je reçois est beaucoup moins bon si tu
me donnes 20 minutes à la pendule pour
avoir une heure trente non mais même
caruana qui est supposé être faible en
rapide il est très bon en fait bah oui
ça a pas longtemps il a gagné un fait il
n'a pas gagné il a progressé en plus oui
mais parce qu'ils s'y mettent vraiment
comme les matches championnat du monde
et tout mais karl scène il faut voir que
c'est chez passé comme eddy merckx en
fait un faux que vous rendiez compte que
mais c'est comme l'était kasparov et
comme l'ont été beaucoup de champions du
monde c'est juste sont tellement plus
fort que les autres qu'ils écrasent dans
tout les cadences
mais à mais c'est pas étonnant que carl
scène soit le meilleur dans toutes les
disciplines et ça prouve d'ailleurs que
c'est lui mais aujourd'hui en france pas
pour rien que c'est le meilleur joueur
du monde en fait il a été cinq fois
champion du monde de blitz quand même
car de seine c'est énorme jusque
d'aventis et non
surtout vu le
bal à conduire le louis et puis vu leurs
soldes tournoi aussi qui est un peu en
mode loterie je pense que si c'était que
des matches de blitz en 10 parties
auraient été encore plus deux fois
champion du monde en fait
non c'est assez impressionnant
alors demande de comptes et collector
l'ensemble du monde vous en pensez quoi
bon le truc c'est que ça a été comme ça
ouais c et e en fait c'est le premier 6
victoires bon après tu peux définir ce
bâtiment là quatre victoires a dit ware
deux victoires tu choisis que peu
importe mais ça a été arrêtée depuis le
match qui n'a pas finit en 84 à cette
histoire entre karpov et kasparov et
karpov menait 5-0 cette première
victoire alors quand j 5 0 il vaut mieux
mais il n'est jamais allé gagner 6e quoi
attendait
donc espoir va serrer le jeu il a changé
le s'étouffe un signe à blinder quoi du
nul nul nul nul guerre d'usure qu'elle
soit longue est nul nul nul nul en gagne
deux ils gagnent trois bombes à vas-y de
six mois que jouer bon bah stop c'est le
problème en fait tu peux pas vendre un
événement c'est à peine date de fin
quand même venu non commente la pop
jamais ce que j'avais autre chose qu en
fait le plus important qu'avec ghana
ligue ait eu plein coiffé d'une housse
aqua
et
quand sa fille mais ils ont raté le
match ils ont dit parvenait l'an
prochain à 85 du coup on fait un autre
pas tu es donc quelques mois plus tard
en fait mais enfin d'autres matches je
te vois il y aura 24 parties et point
final donc on compte que les victoires
tu veux mais il y aura des nuls dans
l'eau où elles compteront siggraph un
marrant
ça a été plus
bas
klaxons caronna 12 nuls c'est ça mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que si tu dis le
premier à ses victoires ce trou il voit
encore les gars je sais pas en fait donc
ses parts avenue via nul ça fait partie
du jeu en fait on veut pas
c'est normal en fait c'est après douze
parties sur l'égalité c'est qu'ils sont
sensiblement au même niveau il faut les
départager sur un autre une autre
facette du jeu entre guillemets ok là
vous êtes pareils mais bon car ça il est
tellement impressionnant dans tout ce
qu'il entreprend
un succès nous sommes tous une grande
famille où une même famille où on va en
gros c'est ce à quoi
les cadences ça ressemblerait plus au
changement de surface au tennis et
encore je trouve que c'est même moins
prononcée que ça aux échecs un vélo
tennis est hyper uniformiser en fruits
met donc la non mais je trouve que avait
à une époque c'était la pression alors
que échec c'est beaucoup plus
ressemblants
voyons ce n'était pas une finale et
c'était pas chardy
c'est un premier tour un deuxième tour
j'ai
mal lu un
maïs nerveux et qu'il avait perdu du
temps au tour d'après contre dellucci à
me tenais plus debout c'est comme si je
dis matchs au fenway dans sa durée et il
tenait plus debout c'est extraordinaire
s'est fait écraser 3,7 0,1 mais tu y vas
tu peux abandonner en fait mais
cela dit c'est complètement débile
l'archevêque de la cause de ce match
passé un truc avec une fois en cent
éditions canfin et tant pis c'est la
magie du truc on en parlera toujours
semaine lissner alors que bon bataille
est vrai que 12 12
mais ce qui était beau
c'était le match thann à yara contre
serena tan a tenu à tenir
c'était écrit quoi assez dure pour moi
c'est qu'elle n'est plus trop
d'entraînement quoi c'est comme si karl
seigner revient et hyper content harry
quoi dans un match en 25 parties je
pense talent aurait fou
mais bon si je n'ai plus aucune
ouverture que tu as du mal dans les
parties du rqap les mêmes conditions que
machin des masses et sur une même
personne c'est tout va mais après bravo
atteindre quand même qui
qui a été très solide mentalement je
trouve oui ça c'est un autre souvent
compté proche de gagner quand une telle
légende au capital public trou et à la
franchement était tellement franchement
bravo à elle parce que ça devait pas
être évident elle est resté concentré à
100 pour cent notamment un point comme
je disais à 5-4 moi je regarde un tout
petit peu avant 15 par tout à serena qui
boit un truc qui lui retombe sur la
ligne qui prend le point 30-15 service
serena bon tu dis le match est fini et
tu vois pas ça se voyait la filmer a été
la fin
bon c'est vrai mais c'est la vie ouais
je sais mieux le prendre comme ça mais
c'est solide 1 puis après gagné le
tie-break super tie break et ou
franchement bravo tanins
et surtout qu elle était menée 4 0 au
début c'était vrai que tu te disais oui
oui tu dis oui c'est fini puis elle
revient 5,4 machin puis même là tu dis
ok peut-être qu'ils allaient avoir la
peur de gagner tout ou rien du tout un
tas riz à un bon et l'eau alors qu'il
joue plus à 2003 2004 car il est bon en
rapide quoi harry est super fort quoi
c'est super fonds rapide en orbite
un bon joueur c'est pas raison c'est pas
genre d'élite c'est tout
il est à peu près le niveau de thann
quoi c'est un peu plus fort la 230e
mondial tu arrives à être un peu mieux
grâce à leur sans faute mais ça me
presse à
sanaa joli prénom tan s'harmonisent
beau prénom
je n'avais jamais vu gagner à chaque
fois que je la vois le père bah ouais
c'est dur mais j'étais content d'avoir
gagné un match de plus en plus c'est un
beau enfin c'est bien quoi
time jörg butt qui bat peut-être
maintenant s'il faut un master il peut
gagner après bikey en pleine forme avant
il était quand même plus formelle
mais là bon c'est être serré je sais pas
un gîte harry peut gagner il peut gagner
un truc je serai pas trop qu'ils y
aillent
10 atari 81e mondiale on voit les
joueurs actifs
wen en tout cas hier c'était un match un
match un match sympa
par mail sir compte pas pour le
classement et où tu vas connaître les
motions sur pareil quand ça se donne à
fond piron serena je lançais s'en fiche
complètement que
que ça compte pour le classement wta ou
pas ah oui dont elle était là pour jouer
enfin n'a été dégoûté de perdre enfin la
donne ce qu'elle a pu donner la plus
basse et dur un grand tapis
l'entraînement entre 100
et on voit tible qui revient il n'ya pas
match 11 défaites d'affilée
issue
heureusement que tu as ne suis pas non
il partirait
les macaques et pau mais aussi dans
l'ouverture étonnant mais d'accueil la
verte pas trop connaître tout ce qui est
excessif est là après qui sait si snacks
a réfléchi mais relativement serais tu
rentres firoud ennakl c'est que fillon
ou imposent cette ligne donc il doit
bien connaître
la
baisse atteint même chose lui surpris ça
il connaît pas ce qu'on fait
existe mais je m'en fous et donc il fait
le truc normal il fait le truc normal
idée de réponse bon ben voilà et après
quel principe c'est le coût que
elle a joué ou d'autres très peu il ya
trois parties mais peut-être fait
refouler 3 pour faire cailler des deux
fenêtres des coups ici aussi
il est pas du tout buteur qui est prêt
même s'ils sont plus c'est logique
qu'ils réfléchissent
aux furious pas tromper enfin - qu'ils
cassent et six en se trompant mais là
non
est ce qu'on ferait pas le petit récap
de la partie
fabriqué au canada il ya neuf coups
l'allemand mayer robert c'est bien si ce
travail sera turbo sais pas trop quoi
dire quoi j'ai pas d'infos à lâcher quoi
on va faire un rien donc favre 10e
partie j'ai dit que j'en dis j'en est ce
qu'on va parler des coordonnées ou pas
fait les coordonnées c'était du troll
fable et roll
le titre en question sera très heureux
les trolls à les trolls sont faits pour
pour s'arrêter donc du coup fab résumé
express de l'ouverture de cette 10e
ronde entre nakamura et firoud déjà le
joueur américain qui envoie e4 et firent
ouja qui reste dans sa nage dorff ces
cinq cavaliers trois des six des cats
qui on prend des quatre qui est prend
des quatre cavaliers trois cavaliers
fils qui avalise ces trois à six et ici
ycare hu a décidé de jouer la variante
fou et trois sur quoi fil rouge a
répondu par le classique eux cinq
touches lecavalier mais crée une
faiblesse en d6 et une case faible en d5
est ici hikaru nakamura qui a décidé de
retirer son cavalier sur la case oui tu
venais voir f3 donc c'est un jeu plus
positionnelle mais qui a et b 3 qu'on
avait vu dans la partie entre n'est pour
y figurent déjà par exemple dans ce même
tournoi
kf3 et la fille rouge avec un coup
surprenant à des repas principal les
coups normaux s'il faut aussi à tout
dames c'est set il a failli 6,6
mais sur quoi du caroux a développé le
fond ces quatre jeunes il faut aussi se
propose l échange des fous et je vais
pour le contrôle de la case des cinq
très importante ici on voit refuser les
changes avec un cavalier sur la case
soit en d5 menaces sous les 6 mais si
celui qui avait laissé sept et alireza
firoud déjà qui vient de parer la menace
par tour c'est 8 les deux hommes ont
déjà réfléchi respectivement 38 minutes
pour hikaru et 28 pour firoud déjà c'est
plutôt ali reza qui a imposé sa
préparation mais il a quand même
réfléchir assez longtemps et hikaru
semble un petit peu perdu dans cette
position donc ma nous aussi voilà on
attend la voiture se passe pas mal on
est dans
la série cap express fab à l'heure de
jeu dans cette partie importante 1 pour
le classement puisque a été réclamée à
76% publicité publicité par le tchad
sept partis partis qui joue est
l'ordonnateur et oui jouer
éventuellement pour la troisième place
un fab tournoi troisième place
importante à la balle à l'un des deux
hommes sur le podium on va à carme scène
refuserait de jouer le match que le
second degré lieu au ciné volia si je
veux pas content car ça ne joue pas tout
dit très bien donc matt champion du
monde qui pour avoir lieu entre le
deuxième et le troisième des candidats
donc mano à mano important entre entre
les deux hommes
on peut faire un petit tour rapide sur
les autres partis on va pas faire de ré
cas puisqu'on les a pas vus et ouais
mais là c'est vous qui avait décidé vous
pouvez pas nous dire linverse moi ça
c'était la partie qui m'intéresse est un
titre personnel la partie qu'on peut
appeler la partie des déchets solides
très très joli ça fait à chaque fois
qu'on y revient il ya que les chaises
shirwan à
3,9
ouais bah écoute
c'est cette fameuse variante août 1
un pion
par l'état des coûts on peut repasser le
début mais je passe entrée rapide 1 donc
c'était cette fameuse variante de la
catalane la variante et si bien qu ici
plein cas il a jamais vous fait le pion
ok bon ben on verra bien en tout cas ces
années c'est intéressant de l'époque non
sans trop de risque lui doit connaître
la position mais si tu il l'a jouée à
côté noir et les yeux de la joconde
minutes je crois dans son match donc
devoir de trois idées il doit sort un
peu peut-être là où ça l'embêtait ou
quoi et donc il se dit ouah j'essaye si
je fais une chaîne une façon c'est pas
grave j'ai mon avance est ok c'est ce
que mathieu différentes qu'elles ne
pouvaient pas eu contre magnus ce que
j'ai vu au début le live mathieu qui n'a
pas le monopole de la science is a
déjà été dit alors rapporte ding on n'a
pas vu du tout cette partie on sait pas
de quoi il en retourne espagnol détroit
ouais
tu connais
mais non enfin oui oui mais celle des
trois ruisseaux et fossés cinq d'or
c'est intéressant en deux mois aussi
vous voulez
ready je te laisse web ont cette vente
d'espèces vous connaissez tous j'espère
d'habitude c'est rock avec les blancs
juste ça peut permettre la vente ouverte
qui prend 24 mai sinon donc ce que font
souvent les noirs c'est faux cette tour
limbé 5 to b 3 et ses danses et les
marshall ou slash anti marshall l'autre
option ici le tourin ce trait de faire
des trois ici c'était une énorme mine
qui était abusée par carlson notamment
avec soit 3.4 plus tard etc mais en fait
ce que fait rapporte en d3 ici c'est
qu'il n'a pas à se prendre la tête avec
l'équipe 24 par contre que les noirs
n'ont pas encore fait fawcett ils vont
plus de souplesse et donc il a le choix
c'est un fouille au gré à gré choisi de
venir en c5 c'est un fou yogi et
pourquoi faisait 56 à détroit en fait
souvent le meilleur plan des blancs
qu'on te faisais 5e l'espanyol et ses
trois des quatre pour gagner attention
ce fou et là du coup bah si tu veux
jouer ça déjà permettant par rapport aux
versions normales que tu pourrais avoir
voilà alors rapportent ils partie sur du
fou g5 c2a et mauvais côtés andré
guillemette ou c5 sais que tu gères plus
le clouage ici
mais bon d'un côté tu gères avec et
punta choix mais bon alors prêt c'est ça
tu vois là je connais pas la pression
exactement mais pourquoi pas il joue le
gard à fond anding bas il a raison pas
ce sage ou de part et d'autre en fait
oui mais j'ai ri joue pour gagner encore
bas ding wen à 50% réécoute quand la
troisième place peut jouer ça c'est fait
ils seraient arrivés un peu avant il
serait appuyé saint aimé peau non meding
gros regret qu'il a c'est de ne pas
avoir gagné contre apporte la partie à
lenexa kérity c'est quoi et quand rajhi
il a une super position
il pourrait déjà très pluvieux en fait d
aller en plus ainsi gâche mais être à
zéro c'est vraiment sous payés
et joua caruana italienne
la wii c'est
parce que tu sais pas vraiment c'est une
belle invitation pour les bras en fait
cette structure ouais
quand tu as un peu le même comptable
firoud mais ba qui disait que c'est vrai
mais qu'il faut être très très très très
précis avec les blancs c'est mieux pour
les blancs mais que c'est extrêmement
facile à jouer pour les noirs et donc
que d'un point de vue pratique à moins
d'être de jouer mails pendant longtemps
les noirs sont pas moins bien hommes et
puis là bon il a gardé son foot pièce
voirie
firoud avait échangé contre rajhi mais
le truc c'est que très souvent en fait
je sais pas si j'ai pas d'élitisme les
noix en fait il veut le faire ça et de
préparer le tour 8es avec l'actrice emma
mais non qu'ils étaient des séries mode
cloud à bombay il ya un gros débat dans
cette opposition genre h3h six noms
et des deux guides
verts kylie enfin tu peux faire b4 faut
6 et bouffe tout reprend et souvent en
fait ils tuent faire des petits coups
d'attentats est en crise il est
intéressant c est large avec des cinq
qui peut aller virevolter par ici alors
que ces partis en f1 trop tôt ils
peuvent plus vite faire des 5 bref tu
perds ton stade afin de confier que les
blancs mais papa bessin qui passe tu te
prends un faux problème de la faim
mais voilà bref
donc à roanne en fait il était d'un
autre avis on a choisi de jouer en fous
je fais ces structures donc moins bien
réputé mais effectivement d'être en
pratique ce n'est pas si simple vous le
voyez il ya une initiative via le
fouille à la colonne il ya des pièges
qui veulent s inco h soit il doit gagner
les panneaux ans tu peux peut-être faire
des trucs et qu'une tour loup qui
revient j'en sais rien donc ok il partit
sur ça est compliqué on verra ça avec
duda et les patrons formant ce tournoi
et dernier donc tu dis allez j'essaye
façon fou qui gagne ouais
allez on retourne sur firoud déjà c'est
la partie du jour c'est notre notre
grand angle
retournerais
tour s'est vite et on attend beaucoup du
chaos
boudicca brun j'ai l'impression
aujourd'hui pour le remettre en grand il
qu'à
tourner son pion dans son doigt dans ses
doigts
complexe
il avance
cette eau titled hier
à cette position mais deux ont fait dos
il a bien défendu puis après cette
finale non c'était ça le conte de fées
de soirée après
s'il était bien ouais
sûrement des regrets un pur hikaru sur
l'événement d'hier il n'a pas joué le
deuxième title à 23 heures donc il faut
vraiment être déçus sinon
late
il n'a pas joué le light web on sait qui
a gagné le late
c'est salam sall et eau salée il va
peut-être progresser salem j'ai des
échos
non mais je vois
qu'il ya un truc sur le prix du sel 1 a
appris le sel peut peut être augmentée
ça c'est une autre histoire mais mais
non il a fini ses études il a trouvé un
sponsor qui veut lui fils de l'arbre qui
s'entraîne et qui seraient détournés et
c'est pas mal enfin c'est pas et du coup
il va se consacrer à fond aux échecs
messieurs que pour le sponsor la note
soit salée ah ouais un peu salée et donc
il va pouvoir jouer et
plus ce qu'ils faisaient là et déjà qui
joue pas mal il a déjà 26 80 quoi est il
était enfin amateur 1 grand et tu
arrivais pas connais déjà qu'à plein
temps donc
tu vois je suis pas va pouvoir peut-être
rentrer dans le cercle des joueurs plus
2007 après je sais pas jusqu'où je vois
pas forcément faire top 10 mai mais
montait un peu 27 27 30
jeux voire dangereux un salam sall et
ouais
new deal à 29 ans quand même joueur et
émiratis et ça
a baissé pour ça le bio on se prive être
champion du monde mais
bon il va quand même temps avant de
grimper un peu
bon joueur
tactique
un joueur qui vient d eux a eu
qui font métier rare joueur vais au lit
serez vous à veolia son sponsor
hi-fi haut du côté de son nom à chaque
fois
j'espère que tu es prêt pour l'arc échec
quand je rentre de corée kevin abacha
envoyer un lien sur discorde mon sarde
et ce qui m'a répondu
il n'a pas répondu
aux proches aux boss est mort peut-être
même mieux mais il ya un lien qui est
parti
on va t'il être champion du monde un
jour stardash possible
ah oui le poisson sont shot
un petit message au passage je me
relance sur le kst
avec le caleçon tout est possible à
eybens bas qui le prend toujours un mais
que dans les douze à dix 1 que dans les
grands événements c'est non non non non
bah il peut pas faire perdre de ce vin
ge auxquels sont que c'est l'artt
faculty en fait
dit félix devrait permettre deux camps
c'est vraiment méchant pense que dans le
match bijoux derniers arrivés la veille
c'est sûr c'est important bah pour
sousse pour gagner championnat quand
même là avec une équipe aussi sous
classe et il avait forcément le caleçon
mais je suis sûr en plus ça on peut lui
demander je suis sûr qu'ils avaient cuit
c'est aux platines ou des rapports en
ours à quoi je prends vraiment avait
écrit dans ses bagages des fois ils
m'envoient des photos de ses valises il
a le il a le livre gagner aux échecs et
le caleçon quoi
mais là ça de plus en plus dangereux
pour baky parce que je crois que le
livre si je me perds pas il va être
traduit en hollande et en allemand de
plus en plus de joueurs vont y avoir
accès à dori qu'il aura moins de
l'inventaire de paul
delevoye beaucoup gagné et c'est vrai
commencé un championnat assez facile
pour lui du coup je ressorte pas les
autres mais j'ai peur là la traduction
en allemand peut lui faire très très mal
mais c'est beaucoup y compris considère
qu'en fait en italien il est beaucoup
plus mal qu'en français est très heureux
de faire en internet réseaux et les cinq
options italien oui vraiment très
important steveen bas qui est aussi
d'origine italienne
mais du coup ses mots quant à tous les
deux oui regarde je les militaires
regarde j'ai engrangé rang 10 avions
italiens sa fin
absolument et donc de papier - été
annoncée en roumain on en convient c'est
encore plus épais fab
mais c'est beaucoup la petite frieda
version romagne attitude qui était plus
fin
ils ont enlevé des pages fait était
stressé quoi fin août s il était heureux
tiens ils n'auront pas toutes les
techniques et de créateurs c'était bien
il lui doit beaucoup lire oui je le
relis a encore une petite fois attiré
beaucoup moins lorsqu'enfin merde
on peut se fier au début mais il ya des
trucs différents de d'enfin fou ce que
tu apprends d'autres choses
c'est beaucoup ce réseau dès qu'ils
voient les peaux passer devant la cam ah
ouais non je suis pas aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas où il marche
sur wii s'est barré depuis 30 minutes
ben ouais on regarde sans issue o o le
malaise a dansé sur une colonne ouvertes
face au flot ces quatre
pays suis tellement tour ses huit heures
serait beau qui gagne et si lui passe
devant ah bah oui c'est gagner la zone
ça serait magnifique l'envoi -
intervient c'est vrai et en plus c'est
tourner à terminer pourri car oui s'ils
gagnent pas gentil ou même plus la
deuxième place quoi tu joues plan là pas
de chance pour chantal tome c'est la fin
du tournoi donc là et en plus cette île
elle ne doit pas avoir un vol dans le
sens où il y aurait pu avoir des
départage mais va pas être bien
la tour hanouna ans et 8
ça fait bizarre quand même ne pas avoir
eu la ddt qui nous ont joint l'utile
interview d'où il venait c'est tellement
heureux fable ibid je crois que ça l'a
fait tellement plaisir à vivre tellement
ravie
c'est vraiment un humour très fin ici
j'arrive à être dégoûté il va rentrer en
bus il va pas pouvoir traduire les
blagues sur mon faible libido fin fou et
brown
ils sont vraiment très drôle c'est
français
je l'échangerais fils le groupe tout le
monde avait joué jusqu'à présent cette
position
quand même prendre du plomb à une option
malheureusement non
lord il se dit que peut-être je
fais regret à bien réfléchir un petit 5
10 minutes l'a
vu cinq minutes pour prendre du plomb je
vois aussi un coup j'aurais même pas
regarder quoi
je ne sais pas qui regarde vraiment il
soit une prépa et qui sachez
qu'aujourd'hui mais comme tu as pu
entendre surtout ses 8 arrêts ce que
j'aimerais bien qu'il vous puisque c'est
quand même le coup évident tu dois venir
bam tu vois né pauvre au delà de jour
même mais c'est bien en fait vient d'un
char longtemps been tu le laisses fin tu
laisses pas récupérer quoi
rebelle john key
tempo tempo minatchy
un conte carlson y jouer vite en fait
c'est pas mal ce truc bien de jouer vite
en fait surtout sur des coups un peu
évident comme ça ça fait mal aux gens si
j'éprouve un effort jeu
waouh surpris quoi
le truc après si je dis ça c'est aussi
parce que tu te doutait qu'il allait
prendre quand même passé lequel il vient
de réfugiés une demi heure tu as pu y
penser qu'on fait pour ses 80 ya déjà
pensé avant en fait bah oui t'as pas
fait danser les trois ateliers hiver
terrain qu'il faut prendre à 6 quand je
reprends s'est tue c'est en fait
ça ce sera un truc à régler côté firoud
déjà un axe de progression de cliquer un
peu plus vite
la scam belle réaction du rouge à vue
n'a qu'à venir prendre son starbucks du
coup il revoit lui aussi les autres et
moi aussi je sais faire et je ne serai
pas déshydraté pour la suite de la
partie c'est bien joué
la réaction de psychologique c'est pas
du tout impressionnée par le café du
joueur américain
c'est beau on sait jouer à ce niveau là
les échecs ah bah oui c'est vrai qu'ils
ont un peu d'eau sur
l'argent de vaporisateurs et tu vas
mourir puis ça regarde ton roi d'un
petit coup de chaud tu avais un peu de
l'eau sur la gueule
tu humidifié un peu l'échiquier quoi
vous attendez vous à roland garros les
pièces entre les autres
pour bien remettre les poussières la
nuit remettre les pièces et ça on joue
quoi tu se reconcentre afu
des moments de réflexion qui sont
vraiment étonnant en fait ben là je vais
vraiment s'y fait j'y prends je suis
choquée en fait
ça se passe si mauvais mais c'est
un jeu nes il me fait gilles frange
quand wing un truc qui lève les pièces
mais qui se passe au dessus qui de
l'élève
les deux gars qui a nettoyé anti
poussière et des sortes de pressions du
curling
[Rires]
et sa vraie d'animation n'empêche pas
les parties mais un espace rien mais qui
viennent en appui surtout que s'il
trouve tu réfléchis trop bien de faire
chier nettoyer les attaques avaient plus
vite cette punition
fait extraordinaire
et tu peux plus jouer là dessus
on nettoie bien ils ont répondu les tout
y
est comme au soccer et il suffit la
boule blanche était un peu tes pièces et
soit c'est bof quoi
rennes france est pas bon ben si c'est
normal c'est déjà ça me qu'il est depuis
en fait c'est du coup juste à jouer en
boulettes un point final qu'en fait tu
as si tu joues ton tout tempo tu
découvres la position quand tu sortes ta
prépa donc sert mal de prendre le temps
et oui c'est pour ça en fait s'il avait
filmé deux mineurs dont sa prépa
histoire de
chauffer pour réagir après
il fait j'éprouve à bon alors là du coup
ça s'explique mais c'est sa prépa
non monsieur qui veut option julien
mais c'est je pense un mauvais coup
objectivement
ricard fait une petite grimace c'est pas
terrible en revanche françois faire
[ __ ] en 6,7 fois lors des faits - il
fait un peu tourner la turbine sur g
prend par curiosité et caro qui va jouer
tempo un
bon chien peut y monter à 0,75 tempo
quoi c'est vraiment un coup de merde
braillarde est simple sur 68 je ne sais
pas donc on va monter la profondeur mais
là jusqu'au 22
attendez fois avec le portable il met
sur un sur un club de chez pas quoi il
m'évite à 30 je vais tchèque
je suis déjà 25 qui miseront 60
presse
un peu fou les trois fronts
bon après on peut passer jolie façade
est un mauvais coup mais ses jolis coups
bas c'est très moche coup mais dans
l'attitude ouais on a envie de gagner
pour revenir le tournoi je comprends
et visuellement ces hideuses koala
ouais ouais fondeur 32 avec les naines
yeux donc qu'il ya kamata d'efforts
donne 0,56 ouais donc c'est un mauvais
coup vrai show à prendre sur fond
d'entente il à 0,53 à 40a profondeur 41
me donnait damev 6 011 bédard et
physique n'y a pas de débat en fait
c'était juste un mauvais coup j'ai pris
9 après peut-être à marcher en pratique
mais se
fait enfin
oui oui non mais c'est sûr que c'est un
mauvais coup
mais jouer avec conviction
après peut-être ça va lui réussir ça va
amener une position plus chaotique ou
quoi une pratique ricard ou j'aime pas
nuls concédés partie des trucs à
calculer pas ça veut dire qu'il joue
encore la première ou la deuxième classe
saphir au delà par contre très
nombreuses dans l'état d'esprit pourquoi
pas après alors on a dû se débattre
rapporte l'autre jour je comprenais ce
qu'ils faisaient dans l'état d'esprit
mais ça n'empêche pas que ça marche pas
tu vas pas joué et que compte la dame
est et pour moi c'est un peu ça le
problème de format championnat candidat
ps le format match c'est qu'on mette à
trop de gens qui font enfin tu vas fuir
ou contre caruana aussi
juste trop match c'était même pas qu'il
ya un mais je veux dire tu as trop de
partis d'un forfait
peu importe quelle idée de ce coup et
bat déséquilibré et en gros il double
les pions pour pouvoir casser le centre
gros c'est ça l'idée et il trouve une
colonne pour la tour dont il veut un jeu
très dynamique
problème c'est que t'as qu'à marois
assez faible la nouvelle structure donc
tout ce qui peut être finale ou quoi
c'est horrible si tu te prends un
cavalier la laisse tomber tu bouges plus
pareil
il ya trop de pain oui beaucoup de
problèmes positionnelle alors après il
va manier les pièces il va te faire des
menaces il va faire des trucs qui va pas
se laisser faire ça je comprends bien
mais ouais c'est joli coup mais je truc
c'est que hikaru il comprend bien aussi
et normalement il va avoir
c'est de voir comment empêcher tonton
contre je
reste pas dit qui arrive n'ont pas dit
non à germaine 0,60 c'est pas non plus
un avantage du siècle mais tu pas un
truc complètement égal août a pas de
problème as tu te fout mal par plaisir
pour te donner des champs de régner
c'est respectable un gars qui sait
beauté asse je
ne me bats qui merci c'est timo
je pense et une prépa ou de l'impro
pathway
at il bien pris le temps
après ces belles décision et on nous dit
que bert barbu d'orge pas s'il l'a
battue ou aussi servi pour le match mais
après ils sont heureux waouh je suis pas
surpris je pense que ruud sur gazon
c'est pas trop ça elle l'avait dit lui
le gaz on y va pour jouer au golf et
c'est tout il n'a pas l'âme et la sûreté
d'un mauvais robert on vous l'a déjà dit
depuis le début nous donc on sait non
plus une petite blague de cramique
partager sur twitter
garde
[Rires]
voilée sur mon twitter pour voir la
blague
très bien j'aime bien
la blague
[Rires]
j'avais vu de suite je n'étais pas
j'avais pas cliquer sur le truc
s'arrêter bout qui va être un coup de
poing dans sa
chronique avec la bouteille d'auray en
fait il ya quinzaine qui ouvre sa
bouteille d'eau etc rami qui avait gazé
il a mélangé à fond pour qu'ils prennent
de l'eau sur la gueule pendant qu'ils
offraient et du coup il comprend pas
trop avec khalid afif rigoler c'est moi
qui fera date
on va juste ça aurait été beaucoup ont
un coût deux fois en fait
prendre un tour de bras
[Musique]
allez du coup comme cramique à bosse et
filles ont peut-être que c'est pour ça
qu'ils reviennent avec une canette de
fanta c'est que peut-être
way
prophylaxie dj juste avec un café à
cette partie pas de canettes
b3 il va faire la peau encore joué mais
mon de la main c'est pas un truc tu vas
vers l'avant
zé de la part de fuir ou mais bon dans
l'optique du tournoi on va dire c'est
pas si mal joué que ça ce serait une
partie comme ça
mais là on peut mettre même intéressant
bas coût intéressant enfin ben oui mais
comme rapporte toujours en fait ouais
c'est ça non mais rapporte non parce que
tout le monde savait une caravane a
appris oui mais tu savais pas oui mais
là tout le monde sait que c'est pas bon
coup non mais enfin là bas tout le monde
savait que c'était juste un choix parce
qu'en fait tu rapportes il avait aucune
chance de gagner avec son coup donc
c'était mal joué là il peut jouer le
gain firoud là-bas y avait des perpète
toulon
n'en rapporte c'était très macho en plus
il avait dépensé une heure pour jouer le
coup et où les il a quand même clique
non beaucoup mieux joué de la part de
fuir ou jack non
on n'a que
ça en fait graver pas trop lire ces
attitudes
moi je pense que naka il est crevé il a
voulu tourner à fond il a fait du title
tuesday r il n'en peut plus et firent ou
si on va
en fait dans le cra me qui va enfin
prendre la deuxième moitié du mot
je pense en fait il a beaucoup utilisé
les prépas de cram et je penserai
un an il s'agit de faire parler nique
j'aime bien ce drapeau français
veut faire un gros zoom dessus français
en grand
ce qu'elle est pas bien il car au four
b3
c'était juste ses doigts en v 3
alors j'ai pas j'aime bien reprendre si
je me fous les trois savoir évidemment
vers faire turbiner un petit peu
en attendant en fait on rigole on rigole
mais messire où il peut vraiment monte à
la 3e place c'est sûr
tu peux faire un peu comme maxime
finalement c'est en fait mal a fini
deuxième en étant quand même enfin il
est très bien partie mais après je peux
refinir bien sûr là était redescendu où
il y avait des fans facebook et un
rebond final à une victoire sur les
greens cauet bongo
après s'était battu pour la 1re place
maxime évidemment mais à mes yeux il
peut faire ce petit rebond à la fin
éventuellement on verra
on va voir ding aussi ce qui fait s'est
fendu truqués puis ça sent bon car en un
dépôt devant fut très loin
pas sûr scarna perd aujourd'hui on trop
de risques que machin on rit
bah oui oui
et signer poitras pain covin on me le
dirait pas et jouer pour le tour de
france je pense mais le tour principal
jouer kobe des vies non ils peuvent se
testait d'ovidé a joué un rôle exemple
je voulais quand même
tous roland garros wimbledon
roland-garros a priori tout à fait toi
on dit rien
enfin d'après ce que disait alizé cornet
dans une interview
[Musique]
et hors de france aurait donc décidé que
c'était la discrétion du médecin de
ligue 2 chaque équipe ouais c'est
souvent les symptômes pendant fait ça
dépend du genre si sandro le gang
si tu te dis oui ça va aussi d'imagés la
fia j'en peux plus bon bah oui mais
c'est beau en fait tu peux envoyer un
thé gacko vidé pour aller rouler près de
pau gars de char c'est tout c'est dessus
a à chaque rallye dessus au regard de
mon bidon un petit peu je vote n'a plus
d'autres jeux ça va
après je sais pas ce qui est prévu au
candidat si sa dette est je pense pas
donc c'est vrai que ma mais le tour de
france je pense qu'ils font en fait
c'est qu'il ya deux façons et a
forcément des coureurs qui vont le
chopper s'étend à tous les cas contactez
machin tenu le tour de france en fait
ouais donc ils ont pas le choix on fait
surtout que bon
ben pour moi là là là là je pense que
c'est un peu je sais pas mais j'ai pas
eu entendu qu'il y avait des tests donc
en fait je constitue tout seul tu fais
pas de test quoi on va faire les joueurs
ne saute tous ces tensions ainsi vous
tous sauté vous être contact tout cas
fait des fêtes vous testez important de
pas le propager là on parle vraiment
pour de latitude dans le vestiaire des
joueurs de haut niveau et on se met à la
place de ben bella n'est pas aussi tout
si je tiens de tendance va pas il va
partir
c'est sûr en fait
y'a que un médecin
brillant de la fidh ou quoi qui peut
imposer enfin
c'est surtout le fait pas parce que tu
vas avoir trop peur d'être positif et de
jeu peut savoir je vais tester je suis
besoin je peux positif
je cherche pas tu trouves pas
j'imagine que c'est
que c'est un peu ce qui se passerait
ah mais c'est sûr ces mecs à 42 fier il
a juste pas s'aligner
je pense que le koala calme son vrai
dire
si ce sens tu vas enfin il se sent c'est
son problème plusieurs y roulent un peu
il a bon dos chebab qui foncent dans
life
met juste en fait voilà temps je te
parle pas de ça ça c'est bien pas bien
non alors avec son ami mais juste tu es
pour rebondir la question serait
candidat oui oui en fait puisque ils
feront la même chose ils vont juste pas
testé ou pas ils ont pas se barrer comme
ce à quoi
je pense pareil que toi
non mon tour j'ai même des sanwi ou ceux
de coups possibles
17 alors pas mal
g8 dur à dire monsieur
assange peut quand même en rock et en
fait
foi je crois je fais qu'aller h4 je
voulais venir
l'orage 5pourquoi justice pas sûr enfin
pas sûr du tout je ne pense pas parce
que cette plus attaquer des sites après
mais carré d as un cahier c4 pas qu'on
leur dit quand même
après un de ceux qui a les traits pas si
bien placé il est loin de dès
5h à tout ça et qui est notre trop de
gens
ex
elle serait morte sur le tour de france
sur swift baril la franchise
il y avait un truc pour les super vite
tourner des casseroles ou des machins et
que ça fait tourner la roue a sûrement
un
là tu pédales pas en fait je fais un
truc du moulinet
alors une essoreuse à salade verte
recrutement conquois mais tu vas te
super league
n'est ce pas trop l'objectif comme
objectif c'est de faire du sport chez
toi ccval à l'élite en fait
des trompes à
un seul tour transport swift tu parles à
60 10 de moyenne cette très bien quoi
je pense qu'à vallée à 5 c'est le coup
c'est logique en fait j c 4
cemal d'après la turbine on nous dit
j'ai jeté un petit taille pour être une
bonne nouvelle ça pour ali reza
il n'y a pas eu que pour en fait
juste sujet 5 c'est ce qu'on a expliqué
tout à l'heure donc hier on oublie que
l'ordi il va vous dire ça c'est très
bien
j'aime pas quel ordi en fait l'ordi
d'ici là pas une grosse profondeur
d'autres
lors d un peu plus fort je suis pas sur
les peaux
ok ça perd de fou
peut-être plus tôt sinon j'ai parlé des
super le prendre l'option jamais
[Musique]
en dotant les toits c'est ça va
peut-être qu'une fois en fait a meta
tête çà çà çà çà
en france 1 1 victoire et femme n'ose
pas beaucoup de pièces la [ __ ]
voit rouge qui évite
comme ça tu peux pas rentrer que mon
ordi
un seul exemple cinq gagnants et valérie
l'option b enfin non ça va me faire
il rapporte on a tout lieu à tout du voc
il faut peut être en permanence y a plus
qu'à attendre
je viens de voir les profondeur minimale
doit faut au moins que tu es profondeur
18-20 quoi
dans un ordre d'idée mais c'est pas sûr
déjà tu auras pas la vérité ouais mais
c'est pour un master de maths
un bon j'ai pas de la question en masse
à un pas majeur de la même agitation à
master je constate profondeur 18 20 et
fini à
18 20 tu as un petit avis quoi déjà
après 35 c'est bien après je sais pas
comment dire quatre autres protocoles
forcément tu utilises 20 si tu fais un
peu comme
alpha il n'a pas une grande profondeur à
monte-carlo ces machins bon je sais pas
un réseau de neurones ou si tu fais du
calcul enfin ces deux choses un peu
ouais ce caruana explose et que nick wey
si caruana père et koné paugam ne
tournait vraiment terminée là
mais je sais pas
et particulièrement se retrouve pas mal
moi moi non plus mais
il peut perdre il peut gagner il peut
tout se passer mais
[Musique]
ça va quoi
complètement
car le twitter de di caro
bas mais il un petit fruit est là
ces limitations du gif ou du gif
on n'a pas pris le pro cycling quand
même on a tellement pas de temps ça
est-ce que vous préfériez voir un peu de
pro cycling au lieu des échecs
vraie question
pour envoyer des échappés après
historiquement je le commence toujours
le jour du début du tour le lendemain
un peu j'essaie de comprendre un peu
d'un avant goût et adore du tour
c'est sympa parce qu'on va tu fais un
peu les étapes et tous
ses marques 28 faire un avis sur ce qui
va se passer dans le tour en fait j'ai
un peu les étapes à tous et marc savard
vote comme on le sait non mais on n'est
pas sur la bonne chaîne trois quarts des
échecs on a une sur les vraies chaînes
les pinots ce thème
un autre humain je crois qu'il maillot à
pois
joujou le jaune défonce les quoi
sont pas durs effet cette année le tour
pour gâcher a tellement fort enfin et
même pas un petit caux vide peut passer
par là
oh que oui
kovy tu peux faire mal
vous devez en art ce serait beau qui
gagne le tour
il est de passer votre entraînement
ils vont partout et des bombasses
vraiment cet ancien wenger garde vous
pensez plutôt winge garde ou plutôt un
enfin je crois qu'il joue le poids et
les étapes way
est bardé podium surprise bardet je
pense pas non
mais il a failli file était bien haut
dans le giro en fait bardet et est dans
les favoris puis après je sais pas je
crois qu'il est tombé puisqu'il a foutu
une
poisse qui la comprenne quoi ouais et
pino aussi on sait globalement les
coureurs français 1 que j'ai un corps
que j'aime bien c'est ben o'connor
ça ferait eban o'connor
australien
rwandair pour le mettre le bazar dans
toutes les étapes aussi va être sympa ça
fait un joli retour ça peut être sympa
et des belles étapes accidentées hier
j'ai un peu regardé le soir ouais des
trucs pour rouleurs pour baroudeurs
varoudeurs ouais tu vois
jacky durand
non un peu plus fort quand même
pas de là
mais il disait j'ai une interview
comment ils avaient un peu peur dans
certaines descentes truc inexplicable
après sa chute est mais cette marque oui
mais c'est tellement grand descendeur
que
non mais c'est chaud enfin ils vont
vraiment vite et tu peux vraiment mourir
way sur ce que je sais pas tu peux aussi
être un truc tu contrôles patois quoi un
caillou de merde hein tu crèves
dans
votre inconscient quand même pas des
abrutis des fois qu'ils mettent les des
clous et tout en plus de faire tomber
mais ça y va sur ims a vraiment être con
pour faire ça
ne courez pas à côté des coureurs
on ne le dira jamais assez
très beaux dégâts qui courent dessus
et l'opl aux minerais
l'étape avec des pailles peut faire mal
à beaucoup de monde vrai c'est beau les
pavés
un jeu qui est plein d'étapes
vite arrivants ricol ont pas tout le
début de la route de l'alpe d'huez je te
prends des pannes et des pavés des pavés
à toi les mâles peut durer ce pavé
[Rires]
web avec son ordinaire
alpe d'huez en pavés ce serait eux
je vais aller écrire bitstream sur le
sol en étapes de montagne vas-y 1go
twitter si tu le fais c'est magnifique
nicolau nouveau fake après si vous
mettez un blitz trim sur le tour
ghonim est le no fake ce serait
magnifique favé kiev défi alpe d'huez en
2003 c'est quoi ton doit monter
l'applaudimètre donne 3
je pensais impossible
moi je fais un peu lourd je pense que
même toi qui es une meilleure condition
physique que moi je pense qu'avec
l'entraînement j'ai plus de chances d'y
arriver parce que je suis léger j'étais
déjà ébauchée jours mais bon après il
est tout petit braquet
après je travaille en fait je suis très
mauvais en vélo la vraie marrant mais
moi je peux le monte et toi tu descends
à
pour descendre ça va mais non même le
plat ça va mais maintenant elle est
montée je sais pas pour mon gabarit mais
justement c'est un beau défi quoi
[ __ ] de beaux défis
est ce qu'il ya un un temps limite vous
faut juste le monter je montais
kevin virenque je suis là
la femme qui est en train de m'échauffer
en vrai nom mais c'est m'enfin c'est pas
mal en fait un [ __ ] de beaux défis
enfin vraiment bien s'entraîner quand
même mais c'est vrai que ça me chauffe
de voix sont bonnes motifs aux portes du
pauvre
mon grand-père lala mon grand-père avait
beaucoup monté il faisait du vélo mon
père aussi s'il écoute bon pour en vélo
il m'a toujours dit ouais tu aurais pas
de faire des chèques traités
à un truc à routine team quoi
n'importe qui le montrent non mais
n'importe qui c'est gratifiant les a pas
vus
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya des tout petits
braquets déjà voilà enfin je botte
traîner
alors ce sera pas vu électrique enfin
non mais vu l'extrait qui viendront je
te montre une voiture je monte aussi
quoi enfin non mais on le fait à la vrai
quoi si on n'arrive pas tant pis c'était
trop dur on voit le peu du style est
ce que tu penses que tu vas faire
d'autres vêtements le futur qui adore
les caleçons bitstream ou bep ouailles
aura d'autres choses qui viendront mais
bon faut un peu con des stocks déjà
maintenant donc n'hésitent pas à acheter
un petit tour sur le shop point
d'exclamation shop mais oui oui non en
fera d'autres choses mais le prochaine
chose qui sortira ce sera un échiquier
pour
entre autres constructions toujours bien
en coin ouais c'est un peu compliqué
mais ce sera un échiquier
sortira peut-être à la rentrée ou pour
noël en tout cas c'est ce que je peux
déjà montré un petit truc ou pas est-ce
que j'ai quelque chose
mais c'est pas la version définitive on
est on est sur un petit bourg vas-y fais
toi une pause même une grande pause si
tu veux
enfin je peux montrer une pièce
en fait ça ressemblera un peu à ça
avec avec des cases et des encoches et
des pièces en france je me rappelle plus
de comment s'appelle quelqu'un va dire
dans le tchat
non non c'est pas de la céramique
ouais mais tu vois c'est transparent
à et du coup ce sera plus un échiquier
de décoration et ça peu de ça va donner
quelque chose de très sympa moi j'en ai
vu des prototypes en vrai c'est vraiment
très très joli
donc ça c'est sûr que ça sortira pour
noël
je veux montrer quelques pièces ouais
c'est ma chance super beau mais c'est
juste que tu as pas debout c'est
différent fait
ordre de grandeur de prix entre on va
dire 350 et 500 euros je pense
je peux pas dire exactement parce que ça
va dépendre le prix de le coup en sortie
d'usiné tu sais ça peut être un peu cher
mais c'est assez sympa parce qu'il faut
l'échiquier les pièces par contre les
pièces seront moins chers après pour
ceux qui auront déjà l'échiquier il y
aura plusieurs pièces qui pour aller
dessus
lorsque l'option n'en l'échiquier
complet
fait de l'acompte en saut pierre
président non pas vraiment c'est
vraiment un projet personnel en fête
se passe si ont désigné pour jouer c'est
vraiment faire de la décoration essayer
de proposer des choses nouvelles et
différentes
non il se rassure un peu
50 euros c'est avec ce sera avec
l'échiquier ou peut-être 400 je sais pas
ça dépend combien coûte à sortie d'usiné
ouais ça coûte un bras ben ouais mais
bon
c'est cher à faire un
annaba s'est tendu
françois vous fabriquer localement et
normalement françois
dans cet esprit là
mais bon c'est pas une version finie du
tout ça aurait quelque chose un peu dans
cet esprit là mais là c'est pas du tout
finie en fait
c'est assez sympa
vraiment sympa mais c'est jusqu'à
300 kg est bon c'est loin d'être fini
c'est juste un prototype essayer de très
loin d'être fini là
bas mais c'est vraiment les gens disent
que c'est moche et moi je veux ce très
joli personnellement on fout
complètement
c'est chacun ses goûts après abba là
mais mon petit mon rôle est non mais il
manque plein de choses en fait il manque
à une immonde beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de choses là sur les quais seront
colorés ouais
ouais je pense ça peut être intéressant
ça c'est une démarche artistique que ça
change un petit peu est sympa
les gens qui a jean-pierre m mais après
on met en fait les échiquiers comme ça
c'est pas pour jouer dessus annoncé
comme j'ai vu plein de jeux avec des
pièces un peu sculpter un peu genre ce
truc
complètement pas non mais donc c'est un
truc décoratifs alors après année qui
seront plus réceptifs aux autres - jean
semble
intelligent qui comprennent et mais bon
la plupart des gens comprennent pas
c'est un truc assez une démarche
artistique c'est pour pour avoir quelque
chose il faut élever qui a valu au 7e
jeu ça j'ai vu ce temps de partir
il veut faire des cinq noms
bref ça je sais pas moi un truc
[Musique]
oui il veut faire des cinq je pense
surtout lors diem pas du tout déjà à
première vue le coup a l'air assez
superficiel dirait
alors mon ordi
prime abord j'aime bien qu'ils h 4 on va
le laisser monter voir ce qu'ils
racontent
tous les coups sont bons pour les blancs
en fait
je strokes et bien fait
c'est un peu too much way the strokes et
bien que h4 peut-être mais
admettons rock
racing au celi débris
ouais edf ou des 5
il fait d'armé de lille joue aux échecs
normalement oui mais c'est tour au
centre mais c'est sûr ça c'est sûr que
ça va pas pour les non en fait là quand
je vois la position c'est évident autre
retour à des fins de joie faut pas se
prendre la tête à se monter des blancs
non mais là ça peut pas aller en fait
c'est trop artificiel
c'est beaucoup trop artificielle ça
alors deuxième version sur pedro qui
fait tomber trois d'abord
j'aime parce tu prends doit août c'est
bon moi je prendrais de à par principe à
la tête c'est pour les mirettes adam
pour après pâques mettons à le coup
logique mais oui je comprends ce que tu
veux dire je prends tu vas faire des ces
dessins qui sont il prendra me prend non
justement réunis et c'est pour ça que
c'est peut-être plus fort la turquie va
les h4
deux
tombolas d'amarrage 5
mai mais en fait c'est tellement
dégueulasse avec les noirs tout marais
imagine-t-elle pions radware et enfin la
différence qu'en est il à faire grève
normal c'était une très mauvaise parti
d'ali reza est en fait
j'ai précis c'est pas beaucoup
d'échangés par seaska us est déjà là là
on peut vraiment dire d'autre la
compagnie qui dit niveau 2003 ok c'est
vraiment non mais ça tout il va la
gagner bien sûr une gaffe après mais
c'est pas des bons coups non non c'est
paris qui aura lieu cette ça peut pas
aller ça
c'est sûr
ah
le fanta qui est sorti le fanta ouais
j'ai une fente à début mai at a raté le
fanta et de sortie de la rangée ouais il
a assorti la rangée qui coûte fonta
avant de partir
est-ce qu'il a senti que peut-être il a
eu ce coup et lycées du coq à
1,3 me remettre à l'avant un ralenti
[Musique]
non mais après c'est pas dit qu'il ya où
les kayaks 4 2 h 5
non c'est pas dit
c'est facile avec leur duo kouame et
rock c'est logique ils cachent souvent
ils végètent à me2 tour d italie de
faire des coups normaux clairement fait
même s'il fait juste le truc normal
le truc le plus normal
ces trois
tu peux faire au mieux nos lecteurs oui
non cracheur c'est complètement con
gerla tu as juste un même ce truc le
plus normal le moins ambitieux pour les
blancs enfin même ça même si tu donnes
le fou en fait tu prendrais tu as tu
prends de la fois de le [ __ ] rue cadre
du bloc tout
géré même les coups les moins ambitieux
pour les blancs étaient pas moins bien
en fait t'es même mieux
mes enfants alireza c'est enfin là c'est
pas assez une nouvelle partie je ne sais
pas est sorti de la prépa les coûts cgf
et cavalier e set je sais même pas où
était la prépa j'aime passer pour celui
son dauphin je peux pas tenir tête à
sa finale mais rami cad j'éprouve charge
j'aime vraiment pas le coup coiffeur
j'ai jamais dis que
non mais là ça c'est
pourquoi en fait surtout cavaliers ça je
trouve que ça se voit que ça peut pas
aller c'est trop artificiel au bout d'un
moment
or alive est
plutôt centré sur à priori tout le temps
serco artificielle dans un fichier pas
celle cfc dans le sens où
ça va pas te veux pas ton foot judo par
ok c'est juste qu'on comprend l'idée on
comprend ce qu'il veut faire mais c'est
trop en fait
c'est par mon dieu c'est par mo n'y
aurait
de quoi retirer à la suite ça marche
jamais chez assez d'accord est ce que
costaud tout là-dessus c'est trop fait
je fais gf après tu dois jouer quelques
coups moins normaux quand même le papa
de cette affiche fait des coupes bizarre
mais bon on va à la voyez une gaffe ou
quoi mais je dis normand hikaru c'est
pas
s'en fout de parole contrôler la
position en fait n'est pas comme
d'autres ne va pas le faire tilter en
france particulièrement
[Musique]
artificielle ouais
bonne suite qui avait fait deux tours
j'ai vite bakiev si ce que tu veux dire
kg 6
mais bon tour j'ai vite en tête de
coffrets logique mettez plutôt moins
bien qu alors c'est tout
c'est beau quoi l'uci
ouais j'avais vu ça
mais là pour six mois ce que c'est la
fff qui a masqué sa réponse
serait gelé vue et puis ce raid
maison padf
somme n'est pas bienvenu mais je suis
pas moi j'avais répondu aux dacquois
basse à notre communiqué pas qui n'est
pas bienvenue dans le monde des échecs
complexe afab
je vous montrais bien c'était une belle
réf ce qu'il fait en trail fait le côté
passé la rave côté pas d'amis elle est
magnifique en fait tu fais de la muscu
ils mangent série covert ou et en plus
j'aime il adresse des jeux fait graves
et quand j'arrive un peu tes paraît
c'est dommage la ferme à ce qu'eads
donc pas de démasquer en fait non mais
c'est vrai que ça fait voir le post et
du pager parler de maxime en fait pour
donner un peu de vie pita maxi mais bon
ça va donner de la visibilité aux échecs
c'est pas le truc pareil c'est dommage
ou 10 qui avait fait sa petite
sa petite blague sympa
ça me fait marrer en fait nos joueurs ce
serait dommage du désastre social pour
faire un buzz warfare 2
d'après était marrant
donc petit rock c'est bon il est content
ludwig en fia
gt masquer
les phrases peuvent être trop bizarre
aussi parfois à
faut pas être sur twitter alors joe
jours c'est quand même une des rêves les
plus connus de
de la pop culture
internet francophone celle là
disons six mois je les ai marqué bon tu
vois je suis pas un vrai maître yoda
c'est
c'est une légende c'est une légende
lorsque des rêves que je tonds peut
d'ailleurs même nv elle avait like le
tweet de ludwig avec un capa je suis
quasiment sûr qu'il ait ce que ça le
fait marrer bah oui tu le vois je
soulève le truc et touffah c'est à
mourir de rire
c'est sûr que ça fait marrer maxime
d'or qu'elle nous dit qu'il va nous
mettre ça comme une médaille
des masques
jacky réfléchit maintenant ça assez à
ses katas comme partie jusqu'à
maintenant faut espérer une gaffe
indikar vous sinon on va se prendre deux
aires contre un retraité
venu il y avait une à et demi 1/2
maître yoda numéro 10 genou le yo yo ma
est-ce que tu la sallaz
d'une chanson debout baas à brac n 92
qui adhéraient fois puissante
et carreaux et retraitée en quelque
sorte oui un un peu un peu beaucoup non
en fait il est sorti de sa retraite pour
faire ceci des candidats et il s'est
qualifié il est là mais en fait c'est
des seuls torah qui a joué en trois ans
non il est pré retraités ou je sais pas
comment il a fait quoi
quatre parties calif c'est peut être
aller retour j'ai fait six parties de
qualif juste dose me de finale fait
disent qu'elle a joué 20 parties lentes
avant les candidats en trois ans
et ses carrés pour se qualifier il avait
joué 0 parti avant la qualif en deux ans
et demi
mais ba 102 choix qui
est qu'il est bon quoi quant à moi j'ai
faibli on va streamé to save à une
vitesse de ouf firme était encore
impressionné
title ses capacités à défendre et comme
ça va vite ça calcule ce sage ou quoi il
est assez impressionnant
dommage qu'il ait perdu parti un peu un
peu bête radjabov a très bien joué mais
c'est dommage qu'il aura un demi point
de plus il gagne aujourd'hui car où
tu sens le souffle un tord et une titre
est revenu à un point donné peau voilà
je pense qu'il est un peu mou et avec
les orques de la date régulière
constants mais il souffre avec les noirs
comme disait vlade bakic d'être trop
prévisible
pour une fois la fidh avait très belle
idée de l'inviter au grand prix fille de
ben moi je reste sur ma position de base
mai mais oui
le scénario leur a donné raison
il dévoile card vous y avait une
histoire de lots ayant donné une
nouvelle carte mais sans vraiment de
grandes explications
pour le buzz quoi
et après hikaru qui a
bien joué qui leur a donné raison
du coup s'il ya des c'est quand même
c'est un peu entre eux ne pouvait pas y
aller je sais faire marcher non non non
non mais il a très très faim il après il
a très bien joué j'ai eu de la réussite
mais de toute façon n'importe il en faut
se qualifier on aurait eu besoin et il
prouve que sa place au candidat n'est
pas volée sur ce qu'ils montrent un loin
de là
ils karuk hikari
ali reza qui est en train de faire un
bel et rond dans cette partie
c'est de la belle chiasse pour le moment
du rhin non mais j'ai pris mes fils qui
avait lieu cette fin je t'assure que
même quand j'étais 19/100 je fais ça on
me défoncer un mois j'ai dit j'ai
presque déjà cette suffisance
à crotone élèves ouais mais en fait j -f
6ème après il a une idée qu'il enchaîne
bien tu mets là en fait c'est pour faire
cavalier 7 après réfléchir sur petit
rock en fait je pense quand j'avais 2100
je le faisais déjà vraiment défoncé
violemment pour ça ok juste retourne à
prendre enfin c'est terrible ali reza
qui passe vraiment à côté de ces
candidats
après on verra c'est très beau de gagner
cette partie pour la zone explicable
mais
ça n'empêche qu'ils passent un peu à
côté par rapport à ce qu'il est capable
de faire évident c'est toujours pareil
oui mais toi tu ne serais pas moins un
candidat c'est sûr que moi je ferai
mille fois pire qu ali reza fab aussi
malheureusement mais en fait c'est par
rapport aux niveaux qui allie reza peut
produire on sent que et pour moi ça
vient vraiment devra se passer de la
théorie dans la préparation ou dans la
proche pour le tournoi vous dans la
proche dans les prépas l'énergie que ça
prend etc mais clairement il y aura
quelque chose à corriger pour pour la
prochaine édition espérons qu'ils se
qualifient
j'aurais fait d'avancer
très dur de se qualifier
il nous montre pas le jeu qu'il a
l'habitude de montrer il surjoue un peu
comme ils avaient su rejouer contre
fabiano
peut-être un problème de gestion du
calendrier il a peut-être pas assez joué
tard zelder après c'est vrai qu'il fait
un petit peu déjà des caprices de star
un peu vouloir travail qu parce que il
avant bt l'an dernier avec les tables
lors je peux le comprendre que ce soit
un peu énervant mais bon
je peux comprendre ça ne pas envie de
jouer mais des fois on n'a pas trop le
choix il faut mettre aussi son orgueil
de côté fab est pragmatique et
fragmentée être pragmatique way
après je comprends la décision aux siens
mais
par avant on pouvait pas savoir c'était
pas bien en quoi on peut avoir des
doutes maintien ce qui n'a pas sa patte
et mieux de jouer quoi moi je vous
demande un bon après coup tu peux
répondre
après coup tu peux répondre
après toujours facile après quand même
très différent des parties
d'entraînement et des partis
d'opposition a pas même tension nerveuse
déjà rien que ça pas d'enjeu dans l'eau
tu peux voir juste ton et l'eau puisque
à mende en jeu etc
mais après il est très jeune il a que 19
ans et on voit quand même fait on voit
le potentiel c'est on ressent un peu le
côté diamants bruts qu'on avait senti
avant on s'était dit tiens il céderait
des brutes ise c'est
et là en fait j'ai dit non on va pas
bien l'écart a encore
mais bon il faudra pas d'être une étoile
filante non plus parce qu'on a vu un des
joueurs comme ça qui arrive à haut
niveau très jeune je pense à oui on peut
le dire mais aussi haut que lui non
reste à 27 mai 1940 c'est magnifique
mais
dépassé 2008 quoi donc
on en a vu d'autres non mais enfin moi
je m'enflamme jamais que les jeunes
aujourd'hui
je ne vais pas retirer des trucs que
j'ai dit aux gens même discours en mai
et lui vont attaquer m'avoue
2008 c'est du jamais vu à paris c'est
vrai mais bon enfin après il faudra
encore concrétisé moi j'y crois vraiment
un mais deux heures par là bas encore il
ya encore du travail quoi je veux croire
que c'est fait jamais croire que c'est
fait parce qu'il ya encore une marche ou
de à gravir avant d'y arriver c'est ça
qui est dur dans tout l'est pour tous
les sportifs en fait
je veux dire
dans plein de domaines de la vie juste
tu fais ton diplôme en fête à ton métier
vont être super performant à te remettre
en question tous les jours ça va là en
fait t'as beau avoir été super
performant est super fort en fait tu
vois quand même faire remettre en
questions quotidiennes d'entraînement
machin et dès que tu souffles à peine
ben non ils te dépasse quoi et donc
c'est tout le temps ça donc tu as une
usure montagne tu as des choses aussi
c'est chaud c'est difficile compliqué
c'est compliqué
il
trois majeurs il a quand même gagné le
grand suisse inquiets quand même un
scène un bel exploit
mais bon tu sais jamais en fait avec les
jeunes tu sais jamais où est ton dernier
palier en fait tu peux bloquer un moment
donné tu bloques à 27,90 alors c'est
déjà exceptionnel mais pour une raison x
ou y qui peut pas aller plus haut à dire
si ce serait une ce serait possible fin
je pense pas je ne le pense pas à mes
guerriers une possibilité il fait fou
prend b3 et b5 alors house
moi j'aurais pris 2 a quand même mais
par principe
mais j'aime pas me pourrir la structure
mais l'autre tellement pourri que à
j'aurais joué le coup d'hikaru j'en suis
assez fier je pense que moi aussi
jusqu'à quand l'ordi
et non mais si c'est en tout cas ce qui
est dommage c'est que je commenterai du
goudron mais le cas où il va faire sur
le truc pas très ambitieux
c'est génial quand même pour les
amateurs français du sport d'avoir une
pépite pareil pour le pur et de pouvoir
la voir se développer quand ça aboutisse
est un grand champion ou pas après on a
déjà maxima en français en grand
champion et on n'était pas orphelin de
deux joueurs du top niveau en france
faut-il le rappeler
non je voudrais posions
sa clique
pour le petit avantage
pas dans la sphère
se casse pas la tête à
neuf la d'aussi web à qui on a eu de
beaux champions deux beaux bébés et
sardes auch le troisième pointe du
trident c'est magnifique
or on sait juste petit avantage blanc ça
peut être mais en tout cas
davantage blanc
joël lautier seaway qu'il ya un score
positif 1 contre kasparov
en difficulté sa carrière l'auteur est
arrêté assez tôt
sarda plus le mange du tri tranche on
peut
[Rires]
d'autant plus gros
il faut prendre la main par contre
il va prendre de la dame c'est sur mais
bon ça doit être pas un ski est
dégueulasse et que jfk radio 7 pour
jouer le gain est en fait tu te
retrouves usant et final inférieur de
quoi prairies ça ressemble vraiment un
rapport toi tu as raison
et encore que avons hikaru il a peu fait
de
défonce
pension britanniques allemands espagnols
et d'autres qui n'ont pas de joueurs
dans le top 10 depuis fort longtemps on
a la chance d'avoir un hulot tiéba qui
avait allez-vous la demande en ali reza
on a quand même du bol
après on mérite aussi un gérard conte à
des joueurs comme marc ecko mvl ça sort
pas de nulle part non plus hein la zone
sorte offre en oem un
britannique adams longtemps quand même
qu'il ya dix ans et nigel short mondial
et champion du monde et
les allemands savaient que c'est bizarre
d'être mise en culture pouvoir rester un
jeu mais un jeu de merde ouais en fait
une énorme tradition africaine ouais
mais que non mais c'est un jeu
énormément de joueurs m grand maître il
embaume quoi elles sont pas pros ouais
ils sont forts sont vraiment bien voir
et ça s'arrête là en fait ouais parce
que pour repousser du bois sur un carré
c'est moins important que de faire des
voitures et s'envole comprendrait et
après les espagnols ne sont pas de
grandes traditions me prouve à ce
jeu c'est un homme et ils ont maintenant
aussi le chien of legends tonnes quand
un milliard à schirrhein fois c'est une
recrue
mais ils ont d agir avec à 26,60 tout ça
maintenant firent afrique ça pousse un
peu enfin non mais l'espagne ça
progresse ne jouons pas l'italie
jallet caruana ça progresse à l'espagne
il ya un truc comme ça c'est un pays qui
est très dynamique pour l'un des
convives plein de tournois qui donne des
conditions joueur il
donc ça les pousse et ça joue beaucoup
mieux en espagne maintenant qu'il ya 15
ans 25 à l'époque quand elle est allée
chercher à aller chercher pour une
touriste était vraiment nul comme ça je
vais mais je sais c'était catastrophique
si vous prenez vraiment rien des genres
qui a fait quoi là il joue c'est pas des
malaises espagnol ça joue qu'en espagne
c'est plus du tout cadeau quoi
le portugal ça reste voilà ça c'est pas
trop développées au portugal
en italie aussi commencé à voir des
joueurs vocale
et on va le donner les frères
tyrannie est vrai mais je repense à voir
prenez locaux brunet lowey
non mais ils ont aussi une clique la de
gamme 2005 des sols
ils ont ils ont là bas ils ont des
joueurs moroni look away
50 60 par la raison quelques beaux
joueurs
avec l'espagne sont les candidats à
madrid aussi non mais gère ça compte
aussi quelque chose à manger pour paris
mais c'est bon ça dure deux jours mais
ouais mon la plus en plus
j'avais pas ce qui s'est passé j'en sais
rien je dis juste qu'il y ait plus donc
on a plus grands tournois en france en
fait des chèques
on n'a jamais eu
d'énormes on avait des trophées il me
paraît paris on écarte par kasparov à
nice
on a quand même eu des trucs un ok il a
bien pris de l'adav
sa cause les finales de la ligue des
champions et c'est ça sa tombe et
imagine tu as les supporters anglais qui
débarque à la candidate est très très
mal ouais ouais
le cas du monde du 800 m des années 2000
aussi maintenant mais je sais que
c'était beaucoup plus dynamique en
france dans les années 90 2000 en fait
un genre de pics de dynamisme mais aussi
beaucoup d'entraîneurs soviétique qui
sont mieux on en récolte un petit peu
les fruits maintenant reds mais du coup
quelles seront les fruits de demain
s'ils ne sont pas plantés
on a peut-être quelques jeunes fruits on
verra
si les graines ne sont pas plantés temps
à des candidats 85 à montpellier oui
encore
on a eu des choses way
olympiades denis de 74
20 livres dessus d'ailleurs
bon je pense que je veux c'est 3
après bizarrement on est la langue en
dehors de l'anglais la plus suivie j'ai
pour les échecs sur internet en guise
numéro un français numéro 2 s'est pas
trop pourquoi non mais du coup ça peux
tu vois il peut ya peut-être un une lame
de fond quand même on va dire c'est un
peu du mans dire de l'underground quoi
notre culture underground des échecs et
plus est peut-être plus développé que
que dans les autres pays mais
institutionnellement n'est derrière mais
under grandement peut-être qu'on est
alors de tête qu'on est au dessus en
fait la fidh été faite à paris non ouais
donc peut-être ce côté fraternité et
d'ailleurs je crois que l'on michel
lafitte c'était les échecs au début des
échecs français le français bat
fédération internationale des échecs
fide et en fait c'est pour ça que c'est
resté
bredouille cf je pensais mais rejette
witch et au fait que d'autres pays ont
tendance à regarder le stream en anglais
quoi qu'il arrive bah en fait twitch
c'est plus développé en espagne par
exemple qu'en france pourtant à presque
personne qui regarde des échecs
en espagnol
en fait la france je sais pas c'est pas
dans les longues et plus les plus
développés
mais oui en tout cas c'est bien ça
permet de
savoir quand même une note d'espoir là
dessus puisque c'est vrai que sinon on
est on est un peu derrière
d'autres nations qui monte je parlais
des espagnols les allemands aussi un
c'est vrai que non seulement ils sont
toujours là mais je suis pas jalouse
grad et autres états qui meurt on vient
d'espagne récemment j'étais bien ça
monte mais je sais pas ce sera le top
niveau mais s'apparente à une sorte de
pseudo néant quoi
j'espère que tu es des joueurs de dsk ce
etc
pas de grosses primes enrichi en amp en
espagne ni pourtant l'espagnol c'est
vraiment le l'hispanique c'est beaucoup
plus développé que le francophone
mais non ça passe à padoue plus de
picwic dessus des vallées il a eu un
stream avec 2,8 millions de personnes et
à quelques jours en espagnol
c'est un combat de boxe entre de
streamers
en belgique où elle s'était vous quoi
après ça a été refusé il y aurait eu
beaucoup de l'audience fait un truc
comme ça
3,3 millions et
c'est triste brno en face et bad
les candidats en fait je pense que ça
devrait beaucoup plus de vue si à un
moment donné bon ba tan et pau jeu j'en
ai marre en fait je me lève machin il se
passe rien je vous mets sur la gueule
quoi
en france si ça arrive on arrive à
peut-être à 700 800 milles sur un combat
de boxe entre escrime euros est possible
possible
non l'espagnol normalement ils font
trois à quatre fois plus que nous et
c'est à peu près ça oui mais c'est vrai
que les échecs ça n'a pas pris
shi pourra casser la gueule à
churchill a fait d'un jeu de nature je
n'ai pas vu
mais tu veux pas la petite finale mais
quand
tu auras il a passé trois que je
m'attendais mais après ça peut tourner
du cou qui s'est
pas rêver mieux
faire tour d un c4 des trucs oui mais je
pense que c'est enfin ça reste trois
résultats en un sens quoi
puisse faire ce qu'il fait pas d'âme
deux temps aucune chance à kenora c'est
ça ouais
ok négoce a fait nul je les montre et ça
c'est vraiment en fait je vois la
position
mais c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour le tournoi ça serait ok mais en
fait c'est qui il a pris l'avion dépôt
de prendre zéro risque quoi quand tu
prends pas le risque à ce jeu est à ce
niveau là c'est dur de gagner bon ça si
ni tong épaules on peut aller voir ce à
l'instar des caméras
sari pauline
ripoliné casa 8b c est
ce qu ils vont jusqu où quarante trois
ont suffi pour faire nul trois femmes
position suffit
scandent retrait pas un ailleurs
il fait des petits à
bien jouer à radier quand même un qui
tient à ce tournoi
n'est pas là un peu déçu camille fait il
fait la grimace il nous met un peu la
pression mais moins
mais bon tu vas se gardent de passes
gérer trop tôt voilà il commandait une
charte est un peu trop tôt m
[Musique]
prendre les relais
notamment il adore une partie et sera
peut-être plus dans le doute de jouer
quoi
ça peut ça peut profiter à ali reza mais
il faut gagner aujourd'hui
profiter ding illégal est un pion ding
est bouffé le plus étroit
ça va être la partie du jour je pense ça
sent la grosse game côté ding
ce parent en anglais ces deux-là
radjabov habite à moscou donc ça
m'étonnerait
bon j'aime pas les besoins de tijuana
ça devient un peu bizarre mais il va il
va la sauver à l'est on a confiance en
fabiano touché pince non attaquable
castaing qui fait de la merde à la fois
celle qui a enfermé avec la tête ont
attaqué des pipots quoi enfin donc tu as
beaucoup de points faibles dans ta
position
ça a l'air de bien aller à l'époque ali
reza la gagne maintenant c'est lui qui a
les clés du tournoi fab il a les clés du
camion pour remonter
il gagne aujourd'hui remonte qu'à deux
points de dépôt me archi sera encore
quatre rondes pour revenir
au le battre avec les noirs à battre
avec les noirs et sûrs mais à un point
il reste trois parties tu gagne encore 2
2 trois parties d'affilée tes premiers
ça commence aujourd'hui il faut gagner
vraiment dur est ce qu il reste 4 noir
et blanc
n'ont sûrement trois noirs de blancs il
est beaucoup de blanc
il donnera beaucoup de noirs
complexe
des jolis messages dans le chat
mais c'est une fille calme et tu y crois
pas très et s'ils gagnent cinq parties
d'affilée dont quatre avec les noirs il
pourrait gagner les candidats
c'est encore faisable fab a tant que
mathématiquement c'est faisable faut la
tourner par contre une défaite
aujourd'hui serait quasiment
éliminatoire avec trois points de retard
sur les pots en quatre parties ce serait
quand même difficile mais battue il sait
quatre victoires d'affilée et tout d'un
coup on est là de retour
ça passe vraiment par une victoire
aujourd'hui absolument obligatoire nul
ça semblerait trop tard même si même si
on en a déjà vu
ces faits siglo sa part de ce cavalier
sinko peut-être
perdre trois parties en quatre matches
face à du joueur tape world est
complètement et oui il faudrait ça qu'on
juillet avec quelques défaites de
caruana aussi mais tout est encore
possible
et oui duda gagnon aujourd'hui mais en
fait si duda gagne et que le h2 gagne
mais peut il encore un point fait toi
aimer peau d'âne et poney très loin
d'autres atteintes et ça se comprend
qu'ils fassent des nuls en fait
faut qu'ils en perdent une
2 2 même
blague à part on est évidemment totale
complètement dingue dans ce type de
tournoi les trois top niveau jeu dans
rain man les candidats j'ai pas mémoire
de taylor a montana en fait
après
clinique avait failli le faire n'était
pas parti de ces gens n'ont même
pas ce que c'était clair yakine il avait
failli s'étouffer oui les filles partent
avec -1 il a fait face au retournement
oui oui mais il n'avait pas fait non aux
pressions par l'europe la seconde place
peut-être
peut-être ding en fait peut le faire en
vrai en vrai le seul qui peut le faire
c'est ding médine qui peut vraiment
parce qu'en fait c'est le seul qui est
quasiment gagnant toutes les game en
fait blanc ou noir jarry gagne
aujourd'hui reprend les blancs fin à
tout d'un coup il ya un pour enfin je
sais pas c'est mais après il a déjà joué
mais pose sa question
digne et lavez les blancs les noirs
contre ali reza là les
deux les planches un
bf parti
à les ajouts blanc quand renée paule
ding
doux que trois fois les noirs
wedding ce n'est pas le favori de
kasparov était le favori de beaucoup de
monde mais pas pour moi non mais après
sur le jeu et où tu dis que s'il avait
une préparation adéquate même s'il a
déjà trois jours avant peut-être ouais
ça aurait changé beaucoup de choses
allaient tourner d'un me 6
moi j'y crois alireza aujourd'hui à
icare où il n'a pas l'air de faire la
game de sa vie non plus en fait du coup
j'y crois
j'aime bien avec les blancs
le roi n'en est plus faible et a pas
tellement d'attac oui mais bon allez
et de planus pas de vlad us c'est
trading étaient aussi le pré le fabrique
de nostra planus
l'alter ego de vlad us il ya toujours
tort le cas cros 2 c'est le cas cros
devrait y abat creux qui a cru y avait
là du cv l'anus quoi
le monde si le vélo elles ne sont pas en
trop
nafa beffa voci
les magnus
c'est pas possible
bon je sais un petit peu accéléré on est
des grands réflexion des bulles la bombe
à quelques coups qui je joue quand même
quelques coups qui joue à quelques clics
3 c'est joli magnus en magnésium c'est
de la merde elle est très fine celle là
ah oui quand elle est magnifique c'est
la joojoo
four
alors voilà
notre chat a du talent
ouais non c'est exceptionnel
ça je m'y attendais pas c'est magnifique
à l'énorme
aulas j'ai quasiment envie de la récup
pour twitter c'est la
bogoss celle là
ouais bon c'est franchement très haut
niveau
elle est incroyable celle-là
mendeleïev douay
ah ouais non salle elle est incroyable
est ce qu'un joueur peut parler un autre
joueur pour ce qui s'est levé
normalement non
et elle marche dans toutes les langues
way
par pitié twitter direct
que je fasse un screen aucun screen pour
rendre à césar ce qui appartient à césar
fab mais sa part en twittant
joue
sa part en tweets
cpu non je souhaite être notre chat a du
talent
je vais pas faire bugger l'ordi
mais elle est beaucoup trop belle pour
ne pas la prendre
le truc qui va partir
ouais le titre
non non il ya des ya des très très bon
montrez-vous te l'a
bien vu les femmes en fête qui fabrique
harry
il faut cliquer dessus mais bon peu
importe ah les femmes on passe à autre
chose place au jeu
alireza toujours en difficulté
qui comme d'habitude réfléchi un petit
peu trop à notre goût un
vrai bon il a pas une potion simple
simple à jouer un
ace que bas comme je disais avant roi au
centre qui va par ok donc un peu faible
- bon développement et parce que c'est
mon attaque donc il est plutôt moins
bien
donc à chercher un truc qu'on vient à
peu près
réponse est pas une position
catastrophique non plus
en fait j si l'afld fait des choix
étrange 1 aussi étrange que la caméra
il ya quelques petits bugs l'a
dernièrement ouais ouais
un
amalgame
affrontements du jour oui c'est vrai
on fait un petit passage comme j'essaye
juste de les faire tourner pour revenir
espérer que salah
redémarre entre guillemets même si je
crois pas que ce soit le cas on va
fabien en difficulté duda pas en
confiance à l'efo qui craint que joueur
polonais pour laisser l'italien en
course
faire durant je pense pas que 12 heures
ça va jouer côte a dit rezaï affaire
d'âme ses 6 il attaque le pion c2 est ce
que ça va être vu
par hikaru situe la taxe vraiment
d'ailleurs tu veux dire torcéen dame
prend et de temps pensez imite ses 5
608 recettes ils l'attaquent vraiment
méchante ya juste faire ces 3 ou c4
je pense juste et trois en fait ces cas
peut-être dans la case des cinq
mois je sais pas il fait comme il veut
les deux coups en tout cas c'est logique
c'est 3 6 4 alors que matthew indique
aaron à la jauge s'enfle m mais on dit
plus facile à jouer pour les noirs mais
je suis pas certain l'autre jour hadji
s'est fait dominer la caruana grave
tu vois là je la sera donné pot de fer
rien c'est magnifique en fait
en fait le seul truc ou
caronna il a raison d'essayer et puis si
paris perd et si j'allais deuxième place
joue pour quelque chose c'est vraiment
débile de mettre le second en finale
julien du monde ah bah oui pas intérêt à
chercher annoncé le mec trois mois enfin
oui puis en plus ça fausse tellement pas
sage c'est us avec la seconde place
c'est eh bien oui nabil hadjarab a
strategy après une chose est quasi asie
ont fini premiers des 30 on va faire ça
en fait ils vont le faire contre paris
mais me
donne juste le titre au premier et basta
quoi tu refais ric ur faire un candidat
ouais bah oui tu donnes fin en fait tu
fais le premier qui sera en match et tu
fais un candidat dès l'année prochaine
fin accélère ton cycle en fait façon
ainsi que tous les deux ans et pas assez
quoi enfin je peux du monde chaque année
d'accord pas assez normal avec un autre
format peut-être un truc élimination on
peut être le champion rentrer à un
moment tu pas directement finale mais
tard dans le tableau et le champion
reste champion fab et sur son fauteuil
il serait avec sambou fauteuils rouges
disent très bien quoi pascoe qu'il paye
à la fin pour laisser champions cinq
cent mille euros je reste au champion et
il reste
à nice va jouer tout le monde le dit li
croatie sans même en fait il a déclaré
ça devrait battant pire tu es là dessus
mais carrément baffe aucun moment c'est
dire quoi est-ce que c'est un homme de
parole ou pas en fait est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui on peut faire confiance ou
pas
bonjour à sa place je partirai pas je
regarderai le match mais bon après si
les échecs bougent pas assez vite pour
justifier un championnat annuel je
trouve
on aura le temps de le faire a vu le
nombre de tournois qui servent à rien
qu'ils font
non mais ça serait comme le tennis tu as
ton masters de fin de saison voilà tout
va ça
va tu construiras tout sur ce cycle
chaque année quoi ce qui est cool ça
ferait un suivi de saison il y aura un
enchaînement logique dans les tournois
rebouché pas façon tout va vraiment pas
ça pas mal quoi
et c'est pas ça assez peu festive
brossac on trouve un majeur après voit
dans l'esprit je préfère gagner un grand
chelem que le master's mais ça compte
comme un gros titres mais là je vois un
truc plus important pas d'appeler
master's échec injuste championnat du
monde mais dans l'esprit du truc
après au tennis souvent c'est exact sur
les rotules au masters pas toujours le
meilleur qui gagne
il pourrait faire comme à la boxe ou 6 1
c'est juste que tu as pas besoin de toi
un temps on est alice ponsar et tu viens
tu décides matin mais qu'en fait
je tape dessus non mais tu pourrais
avoir des règles genre tu peux pas être
hors du top 5 mondial un genre direct
vraiment strictes pour le choix du
challenger ne peut pas être hors du top
5 mondial tu as dû gagner dans l'année
un tournoi majeur et je vertus nomme t
majeur c'est pas ça pour être vas y que
machin enfin quel jour note à 10 ans
gagne 1 tu dois être aussi dans le top 5
mondial et à mesure des filles quoi tu
me définit ici à peu et si à aucun
joueur qui remplit ces conditions c'est
obligatoirement le numéro deux mondial
willow et c'est tout quoi
voilà en fait
parce qu'en vrai si tu prends le top
mondial entre la place 2 et 5
lequel tu as le plus envie de voir pour
le match en fait je vais te le dire tout
de suite c'est pas forcément l aube a
dit mme gearey numéro 2 peut-être
caruana peut-être mais peut-être six
rounds jeanne ont déjà en fait entre le
entre dean caruana aînés peau donc les
trois joueurs que tu aurais envie de
voir éventuellement pour ça je sais pas
lequel a le plus de chance pour battre
car le sann
mais en fait depuis que tu as déjà vu
les pots et caruana tu prendrais ding la
logique voudrait en fait donc je suis
sûr que tu pourrais faire un truc plus
ou moins logiques comme ça
peut-être même pas besoin de trop se
casser la tête
si tu voulais
plein de moyens de le faire tous les ans
est pour même organisé un match à la fin
par les solutions sont multiples
multiples et variées
je préfère avoir caruana coding perso
ouais je sais pas
viendront non médigue il sera très bien
mais
il faut organiser un match entre odinga
caruana
il a du coup mettre le plus en
vue qui a eu ce tournoi wii
bon je sais pas c'est une bonne formule
ou pas mais inférieur et des formules à
trouver pour pouvoir faire un match
sympa tous les ans ça c'est sûr pourquoi
battu on va juste se tourne enfin temps
sinon pourquoi pas
sur ce tournoi tu dis bah c'est pas lui
qui m'a fait le plus enfin ces idées des
candidats en fait
où une foule a prévu une carène ont
jugé cette
visite aura qu'à priori
parti un peu décousu honnêtement
franchement
à juste les bons sont bien
et il ya un couple d'être important
savoir dans as passé hier c'était au
tour des cinq
juges doublé tour
un colonne ouverte de l'échiquier donc
si les noirs rock tu fais ça tu prend
position dans la colonne centrale tu
peux pas te faire contestées et
il fait chier deuxième truc sur trois
des cinq si tu te fais attaquer et tu
repars en d2 prêts à doubler tour et
qu'il y ait moins actif ici il a fait
n'a qu'un tour des ceintures noires la
vidéo et c'est elle qui allait devenir
h4 l'amitié au passé n'ont pas tous tes
pieds ce trajet place et donc c'est net
net avantage blanc prêteurs des 5
je sais pas ce que fait recaler ioset ou
rock alors dit préfère qu'il y ait au 7
mai
moi je dirais presque d'euros caylus et
sa colonne et qu'on exploite mans voilà
d'ailleurs il a rockets et donc tour à
derval suivre ça va c'est clair c'est
l'idée d'un retour des cinq tours
annoncé qatar ce que fait ali reza après
c'est intéressant ou comme parti pour un
grand format
c'est vraiment pédagogique c'est comment
ne pas jouer aux échecs en fait non sans
rigoler c'est intéressant pour les
amateurs puisque c'est juste helms et
des fautes qu'on voit pas au niveau
normalement les coupons a que faire
l'iresa c'est pas des coups de grands
maîtres normalement ouais bon après
écoute
gagner mais c'est un jeu très concret
donc ça peut passer mais en gros c'est
la manière vous dites il faut pas pas
jouer aux échecs non mais réellement fin
je troll pas tjrs mento kraidy jamais vu
ça en fait un grand maître va jamais
faire ça en fait normalement c'est
impossible en fait je viens moi dg
premier si j'étais sous le choc enfin
aujourd'hui je veux pas reprendre ce que
je dis pas plus c'est intéressant t'as
pas ce genre de partie normalement
partie pédagogique aux candidats non
mais le truc en fait ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'ils sont
suffisamment forts pour la sauver oui
mais parce qu'après ils peuvent jouer au
coup par coup et machin mais c'est pas d
étendre des trucs genre moi je gagnerai
pas contre mais non tu pourrais pas
gagner contre
mais [ __ ] la position comme ça en vie
quoi non non on pourrait pas on pourrait
pas gagner contre eux ça c'est évident
je suis 100% d'accord avec toi mais ça
n'enlève pas le fait que c'est pas beau
c'est pas bon en plus c'est mal joué oui
oui toi fuite en fait on pourrait pas
gagner contre eux parce qu'on est limité
intellectuellement j'ai envie de dire
mais c'est même pas péjoratif c'est
juste qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
intelligent par rapport à nous deux
bases tulle trop vite et on peut pas
lutter mais en fait en termes de
compréhension
c'est ce qu'ils font c'est très moche
c'est un peu comme on peut pas battre un
ordinateur même si comprend à la
position et calculs beaucoup trop vite
et donc il va toujours nous arnaquer
mais ce pas dire qu'ils jouent mieux en
fait battus à l'écran tu peux la gagner
merci non non détrompe toi alors je sais
pas de trop lente oui j'ai vu en blitz
que j'ai vu car ou heroes title tu
verras c'est impossible
en blitz a aucune chance
mais peut-être en lançant je sais pas
passée très bel avantage ici par contre
la ceinture dolce gabbana ces
disqualifications pour faute de mauvais
goût normalement et c'est vrai que
j'ai pas trop regarder s'est passé pas
très bon goût après il aurait il aurait
une petite sacoche fendi ou louis
vuitton tambon volière franchement ce
serait classe
ouais cette
sacoche louis vuitton comme ça en
bandoulière ça serait vraiment pas mal
il a affûté lâche pas en vrai il fait
pas grand chose dans cette partie non
mais ils jouent des coudes en bois en
fait
ils jouent des coups normaux je prends
pas trop la tête
plutôt bien pour lui dans la partie je
pense qu'ils me plairait en grand format
mais du coup on la regarde pas du tout
mais ces deux rapports ding
et on verra finale tout ça et peut-être
dans un moment mais à l'air très
compliqué très intéressante
c'est choquant alors au centre de
données contre un pion de l'activité
c'est
après ça peut être notre format express
est parti
on verra
pendant mon épaule urgence
à ce résultat aussi ça change seeding
fini par gagner ça d'intérêt parce que
tu fais un sommet atteint il revient
dans la course il ya une page st juste
mal parti mais à titre informatif il a
fait nul
on est tous très chaud pour g4 non
footeux g4 je trouve ça très bien si tu
fixes la structure - g4 caillou c'est
est ce que c'est un coût 6 kg ce n est
pas un coup j'adore j'ai quatre
sets 3-6
attends je vais mettre ça sur sur
l'échiquier g4 qui avait lieu cette tour
des six dames 4 auquel il ya kg 5 fg f3
je veux le faire mais la personne à
kayes pouvoir ouais en fait j'ai quatre
c'est vraiment un très bon coup
stratégique si tu fais certainement ici
suivent inquiets points 3 la case
blanche cash 4 54 kg fin de la partie et
au juste qui y pense c'est du rhin en
fait tu te dis bon que cet obstacle
adamus casse et alors bon déjà c'est pas
si mal peut-être fait caillage 4
d'ailleurs
mais si tu vois d'un me 4 kg 5
mai
fait ouais le truc c'est que j'ai 4
envie d'y penser stratégiquement
donc tu peux un petit peu poussé la
variante disant ben pourquoi pas tu peux
ouais
mais moi je n'avais pas d'amis 4
je leur dis qu'ils s'excitent de +3 plus
j'veux pas combien
ce que tu peux inviter effet roja après
demain pour une interview c'est
compliqué parce qu'ils parlent pas
vraiment français en fait
c'est complexe pour essayer de les
inviter mais
c'est parce pas évident en quoi
ces dames the world mais c'est peut-être
meilleur match pour moi je voulais dame
ces deux persos
pêcheurs qui avaient les prendre 3 et
feu enfin tu veux ton pion aux 4 h 4e 5e
rien du sort au meeddat a beaucoup de
bons coups et les blancs fait
je sais pas si j 4 est objectivement
plus fort mardi il compte angela il
donne aussi d'autres coups ou 10 pouces
et 5 c'est bien il
je crois que tous les coups normaux sont
bons en fait
ouais c'est pas con c'est ça que j'aime
bien son église et ou 5,7 faire dame eux
quatre que d'après attaqué le cavalier
et vous qu'il ait eu le goût et on joue
au foot urbain la même sur b6000 avec
quatre
vents magistral place et oui oui oui en
fait tu reviens et youtube oui mais en
fait être potentiellement ouais mon
faire gaffe de ne pas
trop calculer matin il a joué à trois
jeux h3
[ __ ] pas se ranger de gens bien géré
mais je sais qu'au l'idée quoi ses deux
premiers coups de la turbine est je ne
comprenais pas ah mais en fait il veut
g4 c'est tout bon cavalier ou 7 tours
des six dames 4 et à ce moment là il
aura peut-être quelque chose parce que
le pion sera plus attaquer franchement
c'était beaucoup numéro 3 de mon ordi
donc moins forte poussée senghor que
j'ai 4
le g4 en fait juste que le pion soit
plus en prise et le pillage de way pour
passer la dame se sont créés des f5 et
rebondir vers g4 peut-être cela
et partie des coûts qu'on disait tu peux
faire ce que tu veux tout à leur patron
de rock
forest fit seul coup on ne sait pas à
quel point c'est seul coup on fera voler
un problème bizarre enfin mais je sais
pas pourquoi c'est si fort mais sait
même pas si fort enfin c'est peut-être
ordinateur est cher mais ça règle le
pâté problème à mes problèmes long terme
et ils sont c'est ça ouais y'a pas de
dragon là ils seront là
c'est une partie à trois résultats pour
moi annoncé un résultat est un ennemi
site afpa lien avec les blancs ou quoi
non en fait je viens pour un jeu à trois
résultats ce soit contre genre car
wallace qui l'a fait les cils trois
résultats et s'était retourné contre lui
mais avant quand tu dois arriver g5 g4
dans la tronche tut un truc où ça te
fait peur mais en fait les blancs quand
est-ce que tu as peur en fait à 30 est
une menace des noirs
les coûts et me dire quand il ya une
menace d'une arme
bon bah tu échanges talent show avec les
bons d'échanger les dames et ne jamais
perdre la finale cette envie séduite
choisi de jouer pour le gain cet acte
adam tan vaches déformant pion une
tourne mieux tu rajoutes les tours donc
ya pas
fait ya pas de l'agression des noirs
dans la partie non non aucune agression
10 puis 5 pour duda a alors que cars and
away il y avait de l'agression s'est mal
passé pour lui en plus nous avons eues
mais de 30 mais ça se voit que c'est un
vrai buteur regardez ces terribles avec
les pièces la femme a deux très forte un
étranger un qui va arriver ouais
bon bonnet pour normalement ça va gagner
le temps puisque 40 à mettre hors course
et
après il ya que le hajj qui peut le
battre on voyait que le h pour l'arrêter
en fait je sais qu'il peut l'arrêter par
là peut-être la 5g lui c'est qu'ils
veulent arrêter peut-être hikaru quoi
y'a plus que hikaru en fait non mais
t'es trop loin je pense bah oui mais va
être un point et demi c'est gagner
aujourd'hui donc si le bas dans le
head's up rim et carol-ann ware il joue
toujours le même truc mais c'est ça la
bas-rhinoise d'affaires d'amd khaldun me
casser c'est la seule chance faire je
sais très bien sûr
social alors qui peut l'arrêter
peut-être le h mais pas la 5g
la cinq jeunes à madrid elle n'arrêtera
pas quoi
montre un john et paul webb après faire
le truc c'est contre hadjar il n'a pas
foutu la partie la poubelle c'est juste
radja qui fait une très bonne partie
pour le coup
c'est pas comme si les nuls ils
pouvaient accepter nul on lui a proposé
ou
bradja fait ça parte il a mieux joué que
lui donc
il n'y avait pas moyen
l effet les voir mais après cette partie
on verra bien en fait ainsi on va gagner
parce que s'il ya une patte façon il va
rien arrêté du tout
hyper imagine que millar être encore
moins mais après bravo à une époque
hyper contre aucun voir ma peur et warm
up boys qui lui si ce pas lui faire mal
il a la recette
un dépôt et la petite réussite de vapeur
contre hikaru
d'aller cueillir le point offert par
rapporte mais bon bah écoute fait
d'avoir la bonne position
attention a dit nathan nancy on a un qui
peut revenir ses peintures wydadis était
un groupe dig caruana bouchta riding
hikaru sa position et qui commence à
collaborer rouler ensemble
on a très mal dans le foot user même
espace alors
assis car oui je t'emmène juba année
pochelu ramène on est tous les deux ans
un demi point et
il a plus on tourne plus celui de jouer
c'est le bordel instaurons lieu chez
paco explique donc j'y comprends rien et
que la gagne et potentats ordi donne
besoin quasiment plus un pour les noirs
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi mais en
essence et on peux pas vous dire
ok dont le roi blanc peut passer en
danger avec cette fois 7 à des âmes g6
damage cinq matches
et plus laurent blanc qui a l'air
tranquille qui peut être en danger plane
d'ailleurs on dit n'est pas il a eu le
beau lui maxime caijing cincy de l'avion
récolte un ou deux cadeaux de rapporter
compagnie gré mais c'est un tournoi
enfin ce genre de toi il faut de la
réussite tu peux pas les gagner 100 donc
on va décider que les formats
championnat comme ça c'est là oui tu es
vraiment bien sûr que c'est le meilleur
qui gagne mais en fait c'est non mais
aussi les femmes non mais tu vas payer
deux fois de suite par schott non mais
bien sûr que non mais c'est pas ce que
je veux dire non mais
d'avoir de la réussite non mais dont je
pourrais je le tournoi battue par la
suite que je ne gagnerai pas c'est sûr
mais là il a eu turbo billets ou plus de
turbo réussite dans celui-là que dans le
précédent jusqu'à maintenant en fait
n'est pas jamais rapporté après c'est un
pas si étonnant parce que des fois il
fait des trucs qui
m'a pris après faut dire que le line up
est un peu je ne connaissais pas la p3
fille connaissait pas le à 50 euros non
plus ouais contre duda il ya de la
partie
d'après match mais je lui je le crois en
fait il va pas mentir et 10 mois en fait
j'ai rien préparé j'étais un peu trop
dégoûté mais ch'est qui m'ont fait
petrov je suis 3g trois fins il louis
boujard et préparer eux
mêmes et à plus de loose cannon dans ce
candidat que dans l'autre c'est vraiment
des loose cannon en fait c'est choisir
c'est peut-être plus à cause des joueurs
cette impression et le fait qu'il ait
pris d'inga la première quand il était
en jet lag
s'ils gagnent aujourd'hui digne c'est
important mais bouteille gagne une fois
une partie où
b5 c'était pas un des coûts subirait pas
leur dis mais je comprends très bien le
principe il veut il peut se faire du
contrôle de la barre
c'est pas mal après
non franchement qui réfute un pousser à
nouveau poussé 5 c'est pas sûr qu'il ait
ses patients c'est pas le plus naturel
mais extrêmement logique quand tu penses
à d'american dans la foulée extrêmement
logique
parce que pour illustrer une nouvelle
fois bon je fais un coup de mer
d'acquéreurs juste histoire de passer le
coup une fois que tu fais ça je lui s'en
va tu les changes ont tour à tour des 8
mai
je bavarde tactique mais du ferraillage
ceux comme sa cavale et hk tasaki viens
tu as acquis vient ça c'est quasiment un
abandon des retards envie d'abandonner
là c'est fini quoi donc en fait poussé 5
stratégiquement très fort mais après bon
il faudra l'avoir
vraiment excellent ces cinq comme quoi
ça clôt occasion la partie 6 trous
qui m'a j'ai du mal à peut être pour le
a changé dans cette partie parce que je
trouve que quand tu joue aux échecs
comme joue alireza ici honte à toi de
mon petit tu vois c'est comme quand
maxime fait des parties de chiottes
comme contre rapport à la partie allait
dire à tous espèrent qu'ils ont ensuite
joué à nancy c'est pour à cette partie
mon père aujourd'hui gagne demain tant
pis mais c'est trop en fait là
c'est trop mauvais
ben alors qu'on espérait le gf et où
j'avais espoir qui joue bien et tout
mais là c'est trop en fait non mais
après que tu vas pas faire pousser ça je
sais pas mais je lui souhaite pas de pas
l'avoir enfin il le trouve il le mérite
il l'a pas déjà passé son problème en
fait mais là oui mais moi je suis pas
façon on a beau être pour ou contre on
n'influence rire alors aidé trompe pas
c'est vrai que peut-être on va les ondes
terrestre
ils ont pour le jeu d'échecs ça
mériterait punition oui
c'est le côté joueur d'échecs mclaurin
danger
ok là c'est trop quand même à haut
niveau c'est trop parce que là si
cramique 10 niveaux de 1300 je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec lui cependant faut
aussi qu'ils se regardent dans une glace
kramnik et voir que c'est le joueur qui
prépare chi chi qui fait ça
avant de chier sur tout le monde fait il
va se fissurant premier qua non mais j'y
ferai femmes
ont failli qui est très bon public
très mobile chinois
too much
type avec omar sy ce qu'est ce qui
faisait pareil l'année dernière abbas il
ya des partis on la lit quand il a perdu
tant pis je veux dire d'admettre ce
contrat par contrat par les ongs a
choisi mais ont ils te disent toujours
la même chose tu ne l'avais pas dit
voici c'est pareil
quand ça joue trop mal on est dégoûtés
et amplifie ses 5 îles apame il fou bar
il veut faire b4 faut pas les laisser
faire
pas laisser faire b4y carreau
près ces cinq ces classes un coup
logique mais qui est pas le meilleur
a les seins qui peine meilleures
montures ce qu'un milieu clément
façon quoi qu'ils fassent offert faut
faire à 5 forcément
mika ou cap-ur-lg pas une grosse part
c'est bien ça beau sportif il a pas
l'air en forme aujourd'hui hikaru et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya tellement la
place en fait
sa palette mais peut-être un caïd et 4
qui va traîner d'ailleurs il se passe
quoi sur un cahier des quatre ambulants
qui prend des quatre dames prend des 5
c'est ça qui va calculer en fait ils
jouent pour le cheapos il est très
heureux il a fait faux elle fit à hilard
est à cinq buts 4 1 me veut
l'intercepteur qui est des six dauphins
drenthe a atteint b4 cavalli des 4 as
oui en fait il va se faire défoncer qui
les prend des quatre dames prendrait
cinq dames gk3 schwyz cavaliers f5 c'est
ça qui l'a vu à carreaux en fait
il va se faire défoncer avec la call of
de plus
il y aura une cloche de plus allez faut
espérer
mais la future coopération spéciale can
am et oui mais non mais là la partie
study 2003 s'est même généreux pour le
moment est ce que j'ai retenu c'est que
les blancs il veut le faire mais mais
bon après il a calculé un truc allez
faut espérer qu'ils car ou face de la
merde même s'ils jouent pas des 4 as le
niveau de la partie et quand même
terrifiant mais allez
merci pour le chant du gros forme légale
non mais avec un zèle j'ai vraiment pas
été complaisant avec avec les grands
prix fidh c'est incroyable de dire ça
ne se voit j'étais pas là mais non mais
je garde pour le coup on peut pas taxer
de ne pas être honnête ben non gadret
par contre soi supporters ou quoi tu
affrontes la perruque mais quand il faut
faire lors du bilan ou quoi non non si
tu vas pas mentir les gens ont dit oui
maxime méritait d'être assez candidat
maxime lui même le dit un non pas c'est
que l'ex-candidat précédent machin était
proche de la qualif pas pour cela après
aussi quand on dit derrière que vu les
parties d'alireza aujourd'hui on se
demande si c'est pas même maxime qui a
plus de chances de se qualifier au
prochain candidat qui les a mais
là ici ça va pas aujourd'hui l'armé
blanche un maxime se remettre avec les
les grandes chaînes tour les machins et
une voix se remettre en forme à fond et
tu dis si maxime revient au top
excuse-moi fable mais c'est pas tout à
fait la même quand même
quand maxime joumine c'est un peu plus
fort que ce qu'on voit après ali reza
quand ils jouent mind aussi mais je veux
non mais là on va pas le juger sur cette
tournée en bus est parti je te dis juste
que quand maxime joumine il joue très
bien il joue très bien et il joue pas
forcément moins bien qu'un alireza mail
non plus après on n'a pas trop vu maxime
l
après le voilà mais il a dû aussi gérer
la phase retour des candidats issus des
choses
2003 c'est dur quand même bah ouais
c'est dur pour moi quoi
ça veut dire que c'est mon niveau enfin
la partie
franchement
avait tué en 2003 qui joue comme ça je
suis content
normalement mais après il ya tout un tas
de choses qui explique ça il ya le fait
qu'ils jouent vraiment pour gagner
qu'ils sont obligés de la joie et où
on sent que tu as pris d'affection pour
maxime que pour aller à gaza c'est
normal maxime c'est mon ami vient dormir
chez moi enfin vers un moment donné je
suis un être humain qu enfin je sais pas
c'est mon ami quoi enfin je vais pas te
fatah plus d'affection du mutua plus
d'affection pour tes amis oui bon enfin
c'est vrai mais tu vas voir ta femme
oui
c'est quand même assez normal quoi
pour être c'est donc un
bon alors à quel point c foot us
ikaruga me rater contre des pots des
trucs comme ça oui oui bien sûr mais
binoche clichés respectés
d'italie rookie one mais beyrouth ex et
sx à élire cleantech sbif au hockey et 6
août ex fc saïda où chris evans a dit
elie queen i want shake shake your body
one baby doit faire jeudi au dessus toi
tu dois
tu dois je tombais 4
tu seras
kevin face à greg nom
et le tournoi devrait trouver bucquoy
j'imagine
à cette chatte before he was difficult
to fail literally donka
title tuesday next tuesday fife pmi
arabe
mais surtout tu peux me les rendent que
j'ai fait cinq portes d'alger quatre
échecs intermédiaire oui je suis qui est
un gars sont là plus fort bien sûr
on a envie de faire ça je dirais même
s'il est pas sûr d'avoir un teint trop
visuel quoi davantage de fioul qui bouge
plus n'ont pas cessé tu domines tout
s'annonce comme maxime ça ils auraient
b4
maxime ça me like how c'est sûr mais je
sais pas pourquoi maxime va qui l'a dit
j'aurais assez qui le bruit qualité de
plus je joue
mais non c'est pire que ce que j'ai
regardé en fait
tu d'un g4 intermédiaire important comme
ça quand tu fais ça tu défends toujours
ta tour la dame s'activent plus elle
part je pars en 3d regarder de basse et
on se bat avec la dame
système passe une prestation très
bas 8 afin qu'ils débarquent
ok bon si je joue ma bécane je bavais 4
mais
ça peut être une belle partie chat si le
fais pas ça fait magnifique
toujours cette opposition là ça pas
bougé et carlos qui est défoncée
complètement oui encore
[Musique]
pas très bien caruana fido
ouais écouter cette partie à l'étonnante
ce truc c'est que c'est difficile de
prévoir quand ça commence à mal jouer
parfois ça ne s'arrête pas là et ça peut
s'attacher qui jouit
il a pas encore remis la vaysse sicav ou
c'est plutôt bon signe jamais la baisse
quand il gagne il
m'est arrivé un truc marrant dans une
partie
jouée contre un gars
tu y as remettait ça montre quand il
était gagnant
alors il était maître fide 1 était pas
mal 23 50 24 et un moment donné bon free
les mieux et mieux il est mieux et je
tente un piéjos
assez vicieux
en fait je sais que du coup le truc qui
semble évident ça gagne pas et je le
vois remettre sa montre du coup j'étais
très heureux
t'inquiète pas tu vas long je vais
bientôt lui rené saha monde réfléchit un
peu l'attrait confié je suis moi je
faisais semblant d'être atterré quoi il
joue son courroux d'un coup je suis tout
sourire je lance la jeune enseigne ces
genres 4 5 coups bon et je le regarde il
relève sa montre
on va quand même la joue encore un petit
peu en plus ce qui est beau c'est que
c'était juste a ajouté je suis gagnant
après j'étais tellement heureux tu vois
d'ailleurs suite à mon pote mes talons
tu va l'enlever bientôt frère mais
c'était vous quoi manger lui remettre la
main dessus tellement rue louis où c'est
quand même en train de marcher petit
piège coiffe un bravo
chaque année ottawa ce candidat à cette
anecdote bah oui mais parce que je ne
sais pas on aimait en grand ouais on
l'aimé on vend
ce que tu as beaucoup de joueurs qu une
mimique quand ils sont gagnants et
carrure mais la veine des machins et
c'est tellement heureux
c'est kasparov aussi qu'il faisait ça
non ouais
besoin fils adore à faire des têtes
tu vas bientôt l'enlever par est hyper
expressif 28,6 prix pour kasparov
réviser votre jouet tête si comprends
même pas qu'il est foutu
acroban mission ils auraient fait à quel
point c'est grave
bien sûr enfin wayne n'a pas d'alluré
confiants qu'ils se sentent et
contiennent pas de qualité qua
non mais tu vas tu as pas vu comme ça
dans la tête haute
ouais je pense faire en forme à la
pédagogie aux candidats qua non mais en
fait fort encore la finir et inquiétait
de plus mais bon normalement qu'il
prendrait quatre reprises à prendre et 5
mg gadret chaque des affaires
five
et il ya trop d'éléments beaucoup mieux
pour les bleus
surtout que t'as pas toujours des huit
ans fait ses deux derniers trous le tac
tac tac va faire mal le diu soeur qui va
faire mal fab
j'ai pas la rave douceur mais il se fait
des petits jupe ans estimé le texte de
justice est une expression genre un
tacle
c'est un truc de jeux vidéo je pense
à la vente de cadeaux quoi le tout ça
quoi assez des petits bonus ou la
malchance d extra time sa douceur un peu
je sais pas exactement mais enfin ali
dissous en teck de douceur moi ça me
fait très plaisir les gens vous me dire
exactement ça veut dire moi je fais
juste plaisir
c'est un pion pour lui ou chopard grand
destructeur
il commence à bouger la tête là la
petite danse cette pas du tout pour ce
site
[Rires]
j'espère impute au choix un pion elle
prend le jeu sort
peut-être trop la tête ce serait bien
qu'ils sortent un ananas
je sais pas il ya le speech est féminin
iaquinta kenya un ananas à nice par
exprès en hommage à icare où je passe
d'être moi aussi je rêvais hommage à
l'écart ou quoi ouais
s'il gagne cette partie peut-être
londres à l'ananas
il aime bien et donc du coup
valentina y en avait bien ils ont mis un
petit en redif
sais pas j'ai vu un petit clip ou alioui
machin c'est melia nowacki l'ami photo
chess oui tu vas y est très contente à
la fin et lui apporte à côté d'elle a
gagné
mes envies j'ai déjà vu des ananas de
décorations we
argenté ou way
très bons très bons fruits
on sait pourquoi il commence un pass ou
de saga de la série
et comment se faire ces petites têtes et
très heureux pour être un gagnant heidi
fournir à flybe
ne sait pas qui fait quoi où quand il
fait ça je sais pas c'est drôle c'est un
spectacle en fait ouais ouais
[Musique]
j'espère juste qu'il le fait sans son
frère soit parce que par respect non
mais je sais mais c'est beau mais c'est
complexe en séries tu sois tu peux pas
lui en vouloir mais moi j en veux pas
j'aime bien non mais moi je peux pas les
voir s'il fait sans faire exprès et
s'illumine dès que je suis mieux je
danse le foot ça gueule ça j'aime - oui
je crois pas je crois que c'est fait
exprès il ouais ok
mais faut il le fait en stream
acheminera il le fait tout le temps quoi
on fait tous des trucs en fait on on a
des réactions
comme l'autre quart mais sa montre il
fait pas exprès en fait un ticket donc
là cette pratique pour s'agit je fais
pas exprès tu fais pas exprès ya pas de
souci
[Musique]
ben c'est très drôle
marseille les gagnants ça se voit
tellement
en quoi
est-ce que je vais prendre un petit
shoot ah ouais je viens
dans braid
ouais donc hikaru
on
attend à d'hamelin mais bon peut-être
qu'ils avaient besoin c'est pas si mal
aussi je sais à quel point c'est un
renforcement ceux d'alger 4 mai
ça c'est juste heureux sinon ouais
très heureux non c'est le bon moment du
live en fait c'est mon préféré est déjà
trois heures de jeu quand même ça passe
vite aujourd'hui
hier c'est marrant les parties sont
marrantes c'est un peu de la merde c'est
drôle
c'est plus notre niveau de jeu
en dessous nous
n'avons avoir des tirs un chip ou un
moment tu va renverser tout
ce truc donc maracas pas les frais
[Musique]
0,7 c'est ananas gingembre curcuma tué
l'ananas dedans il ya l'argent il ya
tout en fait
sachant c'était le bon moment pour le
doubs ça
les regarde sa petite tête
up ci dessous c'est
mais toi tu fais plus en plusieurs temps
c'est un peu comme mischa
inquiète bien quand tu es un truc un
mandat michel fêter les cinq ans qu'il
décide à me 4
d'avocate c'était quoi ce dommage cinq
fois son
salaire c'est un pari lors d un tour un
coup tordu de turin c'était ça ouais
non c'est la foire aussi la
durée de ce que j'ai déjà joué contre
mike swick ya ou non à l'égard une fois
sur internet enfin je suis plus qu'en
mai jamais en vrai magnus pour jamais
tout court je vaux ping pong de table
montre
beau joueur
mais oui sa valise il jouait la partie à
trois résultats une partie à un résultat
là pour le bas-congo thaïlande rare
c'est pas le vrai ping pong un pignon de
table ces partys de table s'est tu as
ton fils est que tu mets sur une table
et en fait comment je vais beaucoup à
aix avec maso jusqu'à demain un
entraînement chez bahl magnus et très
compétiteur ça se trouve
il faut entraîné comme un fou c'est
histoire croise un jour j'étais un
revient jouer
pouvoirs dignes de seconde ouais c'est
pas comme si on était
vraiment compliqué à dos qu'est-ce qu'il
a joué à fait fou des cas tu fais 7
reprend c'est fou prend 2 500 avec le
roi en 17 18 et après fouille 6 la dia
d'orange café ding a plutôt en des 8 tu
vas pas de bloquer tout aussi vite bon
certes croûtons cavaliers mais tu as
honte à nous de mettre une part aux
différents 17
je sais par des beats avait une tête un
peu plus donc voyez debout se
ressemblent
après ces deux années faire voici ci
sera bessette aussi bien d'arriver sur
la partie c'est dur a
compliqué le temps 24 secondes 18 hockey
chaux
toi c'était vraiment ça la partie chaude
intéressant de bourg péronnas et la
langue lente agonie de
ce parti car la crise est un caruana
exactement elle passe
je pense à pas finir trop tard ce soir
fab
plaisir autre grand soufflet
cette qualité de plus c'est une chimère
un
cette position de cavaliers trop fort
ouais bah c'est la case affaibli depuis
le début
du prime 6 tout à fait black 2 et 5
sari fléchettes
une belle journée aujourd'hui
franchement up
mais monsieur rousset qu'il est foutu
parle à tout le monde sait qu'il est
foutu un bon après
c'est pas faut essayer de se battre les
défenses les plus opiniâtres créer un
peu peut-être un pillage ici ou là et
puis et puis voilà
faire un piège
dont discret parce que vous n'y voyais
car ou est
ce que tu peux avoir des cantons à
versailles et par là ouais oui il arrive
tu trouve sur une manière de
d'abandonner
c'est pas un problème
c'est quoi la menace séduire dame g4 bas
des tours pendables
mais c'est donc fait d'alger 4 ou d'un
match 5 après t'as du foie justice qui
peut arriver à tout moment pour
on a bien hâte de fouler fuite c'est à
solvay se défend g7 et il peut pas
interagir ailleurs il bloque des tours
sur la colonne des votes à des problèmes
talent rend trop faible quoi
damages 5 il y faut h6 aussi un problème
damage 5 pour toi 17 attaquer 7-5 enfin
partout quoi
ils mènent dans un monde de fous où je
sais pas comment tu passes une tour là
où façon du bonus la main mais ça
s'arrête là donc
vous êtes d'accord vous dire que ça joue
moins bien que pressé en condamne non
non non pas du tout on me se joue il est
parti en tassant traduit de quelques
jours n'a cette partie là où il n'est
pas vous mais les autres candidats faut
pas oublier certaines parties avec 5 go
ou de manga ou spécial ding fera partie
du tournoi
3 défaites donc ya pas mal à redire
aussi quoi mais certainement avec de
l'enjeu et cetera et cetera sur paris
mais elle est en phase avec eux mais
aussi très bien joué maxime s'était bien
joué mais pourrait bien jouer quelque
chose qui a fait son tournoi guiry super
deux moitiés de tendres car on était la
digne mieux la deuxième partie enfin
donc en fait c'est voile a eu du tout en
fait
mais il ya eu à des taxes ayew des
dingueries aussi un
bon jour ses blagues qui le surnomme
comme ça j'arrêtais un peu capable de
tout
problème c'est que là comme il est plus
nerfs ça allait mal il était plutôt
capable du pire que du meilleur ouais
c'était vraiment un bon joueur à mongo
sais pas
mais récemment c'était moins ce à quoi
et donc après les candidats aient décidé
de prendre sa retraite les a fait un
petit retour mais ce ne sera pas le
grand oiseau qu'on a vue donc
ciao surprise dans ces combats un peu
quand même
ike et fort le joueur
américain
on m'en fait comme venise où
j'aurais pu les gagner
il aurait fallu à linverse donné
pourquoi lui la conserverons dinars
contre caronna il a perdu ouais il perd
pas celle-là il te viennent la rando
communauté compte radjabov type lui
paris
non mais c'est pas grand chose ces
charges la part et quand on était à 30 à
une balle un peu d'offres et 40 30 en
quarante change tout
c'est pas pareil 30-40 que 40 30 loin de
là
c'est beau [ __ ]
c'est profond que c'est toi qui nous a
sortis à budapest quand on regarde
tennis finales chez plus grands génies
mais oui c'est pas pareil
c'est pas pareil 40 prendre que 30 40
vous avez vous expression à la con si
elles au fond c'est pareil au [ __ ] ben
on ne peut pas il ya plus tout cas pas
du tout quoi je comprends ce que ça veut
dire quoi c'est que tu as le goût de
l'arrière 2 passes et essayer d'emballer
dedans mais c'est pas du dubaï
bondam au caire troquer mon garage 5c
clarté de jouer et pas de choix pour les
blancs en fait y'a pas enlever son bocal
et des f-5 des seniors faire donc
qu'il va ils vont virer dame là bas et
et après ok donc ça il a dû calculer et
tours de terrain c'était le truc
je crois qu'il faut avoir un
peu laquelle il va jouer tempo mais
c'est ça aussi dans la gestion du temps
on sent plus de maturité côté hikaru que
quotas les résa tu as quand il a les
coûts du coup il a les couilles les
joues en fait
j'aimerais dire
mais ta tour à 3
surprise du chef à la fin est-ce que cet
abattoir atroce comme ça c'est trop
le retour à 3 surprise du chef
donc je vais avoir un je t'annonce
ça pour icare où c'est facile non mais
là il doit garder sa tour à faire pour
prendre mon sens
nous dit caron impressionnant oui et non
enfin oui parce que j'aime bien mais la
partie est quand même assez facile fin
on va dire qu ali reza lui oppose pas
une grande résistance et lui a tendu la
perche moi un petit peu giresse un peu
la même chose que enfin donné le bâton
contre caruana xt une grande partie
puisque caruana il a défendu pendant
très longtemps très bien et pour faire
une grande partie faux deux hommes si tu
lui donnes la partie qu'il apprend
forcément il joue bien mais c'est
difficile de juger à quel point
après concurrents et plus aller chercher
le truc inverse clonage ou la variante
chaude
bon alors dit peut critiquer un truc ou
quoi mais c'est pas facile et il allait
sortir le fouet f2 qui avait lâché un
fou g3 qui te donne et après il a fallu
faire là en fait il n'a pas eu il a rien
eu à faire pour qu'on lui donne les
progressistes et qui a eu lieu le 7
mai après bah faut encore conclure les
pubs haleine pendant que vu la partie
mais s'il te fais le tour un tour à
trois bras très bien joué
pas de doute
évidemment
pour pousser quelqu'un à la faute faut
je le crée une difficulté elle n'a pas
eu besoin d'entrer
mais bon faut qu'ils trouvent pas ils
trouvent pas ça je sais pas quel point
c'est complètement fou tu fais retour
c'est un plaisir à ton pions et toute
façon tu es une position était stable
avec les blancs étaient beaucoup mieux
et comme libé winner à la il a même un
peu raté et firoud lui a redonné aurait
d'ailleurs il n'a pas fait tout ce qu'il
a fait c'est ça qui l'a laissée à
ceinture il fait des trucs
tour un 3-3 bizarre bas patrouillent et
non en fait le truc évidemment on dit
peter la faiblesse elle est là dans
cette colonne dompter contemporaine tour
ici en soi et la puissance d'une tour
c'est comme ça qu'elle bouge c'est tout
rose dans les côtes et amer dit tiens
c'est la cool bon bah quand je serai là
je peux pas en fait tu passes par là ça
tu passes par là préfrits penser que
cette envie de voir des fourrages 6 tu
regardes d'autres choses avant peut-être
donc tu pense pas forcément mais si
jamais tu as envie de faire ça du coup
tu veux pas échangé à tours ça c'est
clair et nature pas échangé tour alpha
sy des changes tout à fait l'utah
première rangée et tu te lèves une pièce
importante c'est sur la même règle voilà
des trucs anderson c'est ça marche
toujours en fait rue d'anvers est
quasiment toute façon ça c'est logique
tu gagnes un tempo si te le donne tu es
content tu tape ça tu veux venir la taxe
avait pas assez cool donc il va défendre
à faire ça il va faire ça on gérer ça et
là du coup ce coup là
c'est mignon mais voilà alors je crois
que c'est ça d'avoir derrière le plus
précis tu dégages le truc tu menaces
vous fait pour les affaiblir sa manche
doivent apprendre de la dame taton
cavaliers dont tu fais cheikh lo rwa
montrent pas ici s'il va là bas j'avais
une qui a déjà sa
fourchette son qu'il vient là et en fait
sa une à tour mais surtour des trois
tours détroit bim bim bim à vii en l'air
ou ça et si on s'en va là bas ça me
prend cet
essai pas assez triviale
or ce parfum mais bon il peut l'avoir
fait c'est que des preuves
c'est quoi c'est logique quand même non
ouais mais bon
pas sûr qu'ils fassent justement
à wana jour très mal
pas encore fini mais juste super mal
passé équivalent en fait
a few
taxer les blancs jouent bien c'est plus
entre tes mains j'avoue qu'il
me croit jouer
voilà avoir un jeu juste un oeil
à la honte est réputé des coups
terribles
l'arrivée de rein qu'elle mon ambition
si jean guy nzouba
seeding joue pas il y aura à la fin du
tournoi enfin bref adjoint pour les
heureux
fait beaucoup d'allers retours
aujourd'hui
pas qui va sûrement voir micha
la petite mia qui a peut-être venir nous
voir
elle est où mich à
l épargne devoir aller où
amit shah qui dormait vrai désolé on est
un peu déconnecté on aime on cherche et
micha quoi elle dormait faisait quoi
vient nous voir ni chasse
à mes chats qui prend la perruque
faut vraiment que la prendre en photo
avec la perruque c'est extraordinaire
zottegem notamment viens de regarder
n'est pot café nul
face qui va revenir
elle est venue à les jupons de la
perruque là pour aller la porte à l'ena
c'est impressionnant
ouais ouais valait déjà abîmé un tour c6
joué
6 allée
en serrant marrant désolé les gars
on va dire les suit
elle va tout casser mais c'est beaucoup
quoi elles feront la perruque elle se
barre avait elle adorait mais c'est vrai
j'ai vu quand elle est venue à la prise
et elle est repartie avec elle est très
heureuse elle était là elle apprend non
non elle était là j'ai parié eu du vent
de tallard allait tomber bryce qui va
trouver
complexe
jules cavaillès et 4 2 rapporte on nous
dit attention
il ya un truc jolie
a un joli
mais prend ces cas il est en d2
ouais c'est joli je suis d'accord avec
sami c'est beaucoup
by filling à 120 quoi pour ouvrir la
colonne défaire ses 5 fu prend 1,5 c'est
joli ouais c'est beau ça ça va être la
partie du jour c'est sûr en fait et
c'est probablement pas celle qu'on fera
un bon ferait un vote
après salade sera atteint comme je le
disais salle du carrousel c'est pas une
belle partie mais sera pédagogiquement
elle est hyper intéressante
ce qu'il ya des belles erreurs quoi et
des trucs qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
voir
trouve des parties de grands matches oui
mais qui te font gf machin ou quoi tu
vas pas en trouver beaucoup en fait
elles seraient la question c'est est ce
que il car on regarde la ddt hyper loupe
bon bah si tu regardes la ddt c'est
hyper facile
voilà 5-3 je suis de 10 ans
abbas qui propose un cavalier 7 fordham
premier set
tu
auras trois mamans
1/4 élèves cinq
pattes on
t'a pas tarder à la justice georges
jamais jamais jamais l'avoir
vu
je
t'avertis et pas une minute vab terrible
mais il l'a
ça pourrait un punto côté stream
reims et boeing cargo à chaque fois tu
dis l'éliminer de la course il revient
et tu dit ça il aurait fini le contre
entre rage il était
en fait la vie montre and the seven
toutefois s'en vouloir
on verra bien joué et lui l'a fait c'est
fou j'ai 83 matches mais c'est pas une
défaite ou tu peux t'en vouloir de style
[ __ ] mais j'ai juste à faire nul
j'acceptais pourquoi j'ai pris ce risque
a été battue juste et c'est moins grave
en fait
tu peux plus en vouloir de par battue
n'est pas là c'était ton problème en
fait c'est toi qui l'a pas fait le
cavalier hk troubles qui avaient des 4
et tout ça
c'est du tabernacle une grande partie va
tu te dis fichiers pour qu'ils jouent
juste bien contre moi aujourd'hui mais
belle a bien vu la bienvenue après fin
bravo je suis d'accord avec toi
je suis complètement avec toi d'accord
avec toi fab
et donc dois dire qu'à priori le seul
le seul
gros regret c'est de par battue n'est
pas
ils changeraient pas mal en plus passer
ton concurrents iront à direct x
complexe
on it
peut-être continuer la lutte mais
quelques tours fourgon de la dame avec
le roi faible on a déjà vécu deux tours
avec le rafale n'a pas lé japon ont
passé ces cinq cercles normalement c'est
pas une position tenable quoi je veux
juste te ramener à damas ou 4 soit tu as
double il va être amené à tour un an des
1,17 il va t'attaquer doit reculer leurs
relations passées avec un filtre donc
c'est bon nombre
d'âmes première ça ne va pas être une
défense vraiment
dans maya plus d'evans a en fait non
j'ai un peu un oeil à côté sur ding qui
me intéresse
le rapport quand même où il aura des
intéressant à ses candidats il a joué le
jeu quoi mais je veux jouer à fond à
chaque jour y jouer
des fois les plus inspirés des fois
moins mais c'est bien ce beau joueur une
chanson de julien clerc comme ça quel
jeu il joue
il se questionne
way
cinq minutes chez les reds attention
hein le temps c'est
de l'argent mais pas coeur
faisant sortir niveau temps ouais
c'était plus la position qui m'inquiète
que le temps mais les deux sont liés
forcément quand tu es bien tu es plus à
l'aise tu joues plus vite quand tu